Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Dewi and I were just talking about Roblox.
Oh, wait, wait, they can't hear you.
Wait, give me a sec.
I fucked up.
I forgot, because you know when your PC updates and then everything else gets fucked up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, wait.
Wait, did everything fuck?
Oh, wait, can you talk real quick?
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah, anyway.
What were you saying about Roblox?
Oh, yeah, you were preparing.
Yeah, it was like 30 minutes before.
No, just kidding.
That's why we're late.
I was in a Roblox game.
That's true, that's true.
It wasn't my fault.
It wasn't because I realized that, like, I was like, oh, shit, how do I boot up myself and the game at the same time?
No, but Doobie hasn't even played the squid game Roblox yet.
No, I haven't tried it.
Wait, what games have you been playing on Roblox?
Oh, it's this cake designer game.
A cake designer?
Is it like the dressing one?
Yeah, yeah, but it gets seven minutes instead of like five minutes.
It's pretty hardcore.
Wait, have you seen the videos, though, of the squid game Roblox videos?
I've seen it before, but I don't know about, like, the videos.
Is it the one where it's like the Mona Lisa?
No.
Wait, you've never seen that?
No, I haven't.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, sorry, guys.
I need to show her the Mona Lisa.
Oh, you're gonna send it to me?
I send this to my chat all the time because it's actually, it lives, like, word free in my head.
And it's, like, basically, like, you know how in Roblox, there's, like, you can do voice comms, but you have to send in your ideas.
And stuff to talk to people.
So, like, all these little kids are, like, role playing in squid game as if they're actually there.
Nobody would watch the video.
Fuck you.
Oh, my God.
The Mona Lisa.
Wait, did you send it to me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me see.
It's actually one of my favorite Roblox videos.
Oh, yes, by the way, FreeCurl is Doobie and she's part of the P faction.
The Mona Lisa!
No!
I love videos online where it's just random kids who are, they're just not being supervised and just yelling at the top of their lungs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, oh, my God, kids these days.
Oh, my God, they could be, like, actual actors.
Like, holy shit.
Where are these kids in GTARP?
They probably should not.
They're gonna be future GTARP role players.
I could see a career.
I could see a GTA 6 when it comes out in 2027.
That's true.
Oh, my gosh.
But yeah, I can't believe you never played the squid game Roblox.
It's actually, like, it's so fun.
It's, like, I was, like, playing because, like, you know how, like, the higher rank you are, the longer.
OK, so, like, the higher rank you are, the longer the queues get because there's less people and higher elo.
So, like, at one point I was in, like, a 20 minute queue to find a game in, like, the top 500.
So I was just pulling up Roblox and playing it on stream in between queues.
And I was just, like, I can't.
I have to play something.
Like, I'm not gonna stay here for 20 minutes.
Yeah, it has matchmaking.
That's insane.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
What do you mean?
My chat was, like, telling me that there's one character that I'm gonna, like, not like from your character lineup.
I think, like, the top five that I play is Cloak and Dagger, Rocket.
Penny Parker, Namor, and Mantis.
Oh, you're a Rocket man.
Yeah, but he's fun.
He's really fun.
I think, like, Rocket, the higher you get, Rocket is, like, the character most people will yell at.
I mean, yeah.
I did see there was that one Grandmaster who got zero damage.
He got zero damage and got the GM.
And I was like, why?
You're not helping all these Raccoon players.
It's because, like, the reason why a lot of people hate Raccoon players right now is because, like, usually Raccoon players don't swap.
They're like, I only play Raccoon because, like, all they do is just, like, right-click and go, haha.
They're like, can someone please play Punisher?
And you're just like, please, like...
It's, like, in higher rank is three support.
Yeah, triple support.
So, like, it's so boring.
It's like, have you ever played Overwatch during the GOATS meta?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's basically that.
So, like, nothing dies.
Yeah.
It's like, oh, there's Luna's 12 seconds of not dying.
Oh, there's Mantis now.
Oh, now it's Cloak and Dagger.
Well, Luna got her ult back again.
Yeah, but don't people ban Luna at, like, higher ranks?
Yeah, they ban Luna, but instead of running Luna, they just run Cloak and Dagger, Mantis, and Invisible Woman, which is basically the same thing.
But they don't want Adam Warlock?
Well, it depends.
Unless, like, it depends, because, like, his heals are not that good and you rely on his res ability, but people would rather just go with, like, three Zenyatta trances, you know, for something to happen.
But it's so boring.
Honestly, it's, like, one of the worst, like, comps you can play, because I was like, you know, like, I played these games before for Overwatch, and then you're like, I don't want to do this again.
Isn't it good, like, if you're queuing with, like, a support main, too, and if you play support, then that means that, you know, you have a more likely chance of locking it in?
Yeah, at least, like, you know, you don't have to worry about, like, three support players on the same team, because you can play triple support!
It's great!
Yay!
That's, like, the one thing I wish there was, a role queue, but people are like, the game will die if there's a role queue, but then I'm so tired of bumping into other support players.
Like, I once had a game where I had, like, four support mains on my team, and I was just like, alright, I guess we lose.
Like, what do we do?
I find in, like, some ranked games I play, I definitely have to play tank, because there's really no tank players, at least in the lower ranks.
That's so true, that's so true.
Like, tank players are, like, such a rare species.
They're, like, because, like, you know, as a tank, all you do is just get fucking, like, walloped, and, like, you get beat up in the front line, and you're like, what do I do?
I always tell my chat, to be a tank player, you have to be a masochist.
Well, especially because they move so slow, that's what I don't like about playing tank, but I guess playing Penny Parker and Venom, to me, those are the only ones I can play, because the rest are just, like, feels so slow.
They're, like, chonky, they're, like, just built, like, absolute units, and you're just, like, walking up to them and just hoping something dies.
Alright, I'll queue this up.
The queues are so fast, too.
It's actually crazy.
Instantly, that's why I didn't queue chat, because I knew instantly we were going to get in a game.
Oh, yeah, wait, is the audio balance okay, chat?
Oh, yeah, guys, is the audio good between me?
Is the stream actually live, or what?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Doobie's streaming, too, on Twitch right now.
But for those who are wondering why I'm number two JokeyBird fan, because someone stole number one JokeyBird fan, so I have to be number two.
That's to be expected.
No, the thing is, I stole it, but I had to rename it, because I was, like, I had to rename that account, and then, like, somebody re-stole the name, and so, like, I have to be number two now.
I can't believe it.
I stole it on my other alt account.
Oh, my God, you sniped it.
You sniped it.
Okay, I'll play.
What should I play?
You can play either a tank or a DPS.
Triple DPS works, too.
Okay, I guess I'll play Rocket, then, your favorite.
Oh, my God.
Well, if you're playing Rocket, I know what, I gotta play this guy.
I gotta play Punisher.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, we got infinite ammo.
When I say ammo, just drop down to infinite ammo.
Okay.
Yeah, and I could be like...
I'm good at taking instructions.
Okay.
I think I can do it.
That's right.
Let's get Doobie the GM.
Not today, though.
I would freaking die.
No.
Yeah, it'd take too long.
I don't think I can do all the way to GM.
Oh, wait, my...
Alright, I'm not gonna be moving for a sec.
I'm gonna be throwing a little bit because I need to change the color crosshair.
Wait, why is it not green?
Okay, whatever.
I don't need green.
I can shoot with the white one.
Okay, it's been a while since I played Punisher, so I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay, I know what I'm doing.
Okay, I'm gonna walk up.
Can you give me ammo here?
Okay.
Okay, I did a lot of damage.
Oh, my God.
Easy.
That was low.
Alright.
Oh, okay, I'm dead.
I did a lot.
Oh, I was not.
I forgot how fucking strong infinite was.
My settings are all so messed up.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
It's alright.
We can slowly fix it.
It's gold, like, it's alright.
We can go AFK until the last minute and then we'll just...
We can get your ELO back easily.
Oh, we're running triple support.
Wait, how are we dying?
Alright.
Don't worry, we got a pick.
Alright, I'm coming over.
I have, like, 300 ziplines.
Because I keep forgetting to use my old ones.
Alright, I'm ready.
You can have infinite for me.
Okay.
Alright, yep.
Okay, nice, nice.
I need heals real fast.
Okay, I'm gonna ult here, but you're gonna have to team me up, though.
Because I'll die.
No, I don't have enough healing as Rocket.
It's not just your job, though.
So, like, I'm a little...
Alright, I might be feeding a little.
I'll go Bucky.
It's okay.
I'll play Minim.
Alright.
Oh, if you're gonna play Venom, I don't need to play it.
I may or may not be feeding a little bit.
I keep thinking I'd live forever for some reason.
It's weird.
I don't know why.
I'm like...
Oh my god, I'll...
Okay, I...
I went into a...
I haven't played against...
Yeah, I haven't played against a Penny mine.
It's Penny and Solon.
Because Penny isn't meta.
So, like, nobody plays Penny.
So, I'm like, I can walk this, right?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nobody plays Penny, like, a higher rank?
No, no, she's a throw and higher ELO.
Because, like, Mag...
Mag...
Mag is strange and...
Who's the third thing?
Hulk is just so much better.
Oh, yeah.
They're just a lot better, so people don't usually play...
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll flank.
I'm gonna wait until...
Oh, there's the Hulk.
Oh.
We got this.
Oh my god.
Do we do?
It's okay, it's okay.
We got this.
I believe.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Where's our other healer?
I don't know.
That's how I felt the entire time.
I'm like, where is her?
I feel like...
I feel like you were the only one that's been healing me.
Oh my god.
Oh, she's back.
I think she was AFK, the invisible woman.
Oh my god.
Yeah, or...
I don't trust her other healer.
Only 30 seconds.
I have another ult.
Okay, don't worry.
Our Loki is gonna do something amazing.
I believe in him.
I'm gonna be very curious as to what the...
What the heal stats are.
I'm not actually...
Alright, Loki, Loki.
This is it.
This is your time to shine, Loki.
Use your one ult.
This is it.
Okay, that's not point, but that's okay.
That's okay.
I'm totally gonna get healed, right?
I got messed up by the...
Wait, our Loki still hasn't ulted?
Our Loki never ulted.
This is just our warm-up game.
Yeah, guys, this is it.
This is just...
This is just a warm-up, guys.
Like, we just...
Yeah, I don't think I've ever saw a Loki ult at all.
Holy shit.
It's alright.
I think...
Oh, man.
The support players are like...
Clearly, the DPS is the problem.
I think the other supports are like...
And I'm like, no.
No, it's definitely not.
Yeah, I didn't...
I barely got any healing from the...
Yeah, no, me too.
You were the only one that healed me, and I was just like...
Oh, that's...
That's awkward.
Maybe I should've just gone back to play Cloak and Dagger or something to keep us up.
Luna Snowgill, back I go.
Oh, my God.
I know I was definitely feeding, but then I was like...
Trying to adjust playing DPS again.
That's what we're doing.
We were playing on alt accounts, and we had to adjust the settings.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
We were adjusting settings mid-game, and like...
I was in Luna Snowgill for so long, guys.
Like, you know, it takes me a while to...
Back up and hit them from far...
What?
No.
Alright.
I totally...
I believe in my...
I'll just put it on you, so...
You'll never die, Freecloak.
Oh, thank you.
You'll never die.
If you die, it's not because of me.
It's because they just...
It's because of Jeff.
Yeah, yeah.
It's because of Jeff, obviously.
Alright.
I mean, Jeff works...
Oh, there's a portal.
Oh, my God.
They're doing real strats.
No way.
My mines were placed perfectly.
What is this goo that's on the ground?
Who does that?
Where's the goo?
The blue goo sometimes.
The blue goo?
Is that the penny?
Enemy penny?
I don't know.
I don't think I see any blue goo.
Okay, I just missed like three shots, but that's okay.
A freaking mantis.
Oh, my God.
This mantis is actually really good.
She's like...
She could actually aim, which is crazy.
It's very surprising.
That the mantis could aim.
Oh.
Look at that.
We did it.
They don't realize I'm sitting up here, which is...
Maybe.
Yeah, we're all on alt accounts, by the way.
Me and Doobie.
We're all on alt accounts, so we're just fighting other smurfs, guys.
Yeah, somebody asked what rank we are.
I'm grandmaster in my heart.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm like one above all right now.
That's like top 500, kind of, right?
Oh, my God.
Loki broke my fucking hull.
My building.
Oh, wow.
This Loki actually uses ult.
That's actually crazy.
Careful.
You might die here.
Don't peek.
You can die too.
I'll punish ult.
You stupid punisher.
That's all right.
Wow.
It's actually crazy what happens when you have a healer that can heal.
We're doing okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
You're alive.
You're fine.
I'm making sure you don't die.
You're alive.
Thank you.
I froze him too.
Huge heal.
Okay, I'm dead here because...
I guess nobody cares?
About me?
Oh.
I died.
I fucking moved our moon knight and I died.
I died and the moon knight left me.
I froze the wolverine just for our moon knight.
And he just ran away.
Welcome to my...
Oh, my God.
I thought the moon knight would...
I thought the moon knight would stay with me.
Silly me.
Silly me for thinking that.
Yeah, you're too used to...
I'm so used to...
I'm just used to players actually backing me up.
Okay, now I know.
Play for yourself.
I know now, Doobie.
I just...
I can't trust no one.
I just trust you.
That's it.
Oh, thank you.
Me?
Really?
I didn't keep you alive until I died.
Yeah.
I think if we had...
If our DPS was doing better...
Yeah.
I didn't look at the stats, but I'm gonna say...
I think if our DPS and our other two support actually healed...
Then things would have been a lot better.
Alright, that's it.
I'll lock in.
I'm gonna lock in.
Okay.
Someone's like, Jeff is actually good if you're a flanker, but only if you're in top 500.
Do people still play Jeff at that rank?
In top 500?
Okay, the way they play Jeff in top 500 is that they would basically play him as a third DPS.
So like, he can occasionally heal, but all he does is just be in the enemy's backline and be annoying as fuck.
But like, it only works for a triple support.
Like, if you play Jeff in duo support, it's just throwing.
Yeah.
Because of his...
Survivability.
Yeah, his support ult is not good enough for it.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
I saw there's like, Jeff tech where he goes in the ground really fast and then he comes up really fast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's like some Jeff 1 tricks in top 500.
They're like, really fucking annoying because it's so hard.
Even in top 500, they're really hard to kill because they do crazy movement shit.
But I still avoid Jeff players just because...
You don't avoid them?
Yeah, because there's just better support things you can play, you know?
Yeah.
You can play support characters that are so much better than Jeff, so you don't want to risk on a Jeff player.
It's just 1 tricks that are too risky to rely on.
Jeff players are usually 1 tricks?
Yeah, usually.
Like, why would you do that to yourself?
Unless you're a 1 trick of like meta characters, you know?
Like characters that are meta, then it's fine.
Yeah.
Like Moon Knight meta?
Oh yeah, the Moon Knight meta is annoying.
Oh my god, I didn't see the Bucky.
I'm so dumb.
I didn't see that they have a Bucky.
I was just looking at the Cloak and Dagger and he 1 shot me.
Oh...
This Bucky can aim.
This Bucky actually can aim.
Yeah, don't underestimate us gold players.
It's because I was playing gold earlier and then didn't get here.
That's yours?
Okay, I keep like...
Because I'm not used to playing with Fanny, I'm like, which one's yours?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm ready to flank.
Let's see.
This is a little bad.
Alright, I'm ready to push in.
Oh, okay.
Oh, never mind.
What?
I'm getting the mines though.
I got the spider mines.
Fuck.
They're like giving us the point, kind of.
Not really.
They backed up for a while.
I guess so.
Oh.
Come on, let me...
No!
I was about to ult!
I was just about to ult.
I fucking risked it.
I was gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna risk it all.
You still have it though, right?
Yeah, I do, but I could kill those three.
I was gonna kill three people with my ult.
It's fine, it's fine.
If they push up...
They have support ults, I'm pretty sure, right?
This penny is like, weird.
Oh, they're bunched up.
Goddamn, get away from me, this Bucky.
Oh my god, this Bucky is good.
This Bucky is actually good.
I'm so scared of him.
I'm actually scared of him.
He's actually...
He can actually aim.
It's weird.
Maybe they're smurfing.
Please somebody get the mines.
Okay, I'll just frontline, I'm fine.
I'll frontline.
I'll frontline as a flanker, that's okay.
I'll just frontline.
That's okay.
I don't wanna flank anyway.
Oh my god, get your hands off me!
I died, I died, I died.
You ran right into my mines.
Yes, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
I feel like I can't play flanker against this comp.
They're way too fucking corny.
That Bucky is way too scary for me.
I'll stay up here.
I'll just shoot down.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I have ults soon.
The moon!
Oh, nothing.
That's a random bullshit.
You ever hear these ultimates in your dreams?
Oh yeah, the moon.
They're like, the moon!
And then armed and dangerous.
All the time.
They live in my head, rent-free.
Oh wait, I can...
Stop punching up together, stop punching up!
He's just a solo, she's low, she's low.
She's low, nice.
I'm gonna focus Captain America.
Don't worry!
Don't worry, invisible woman!
Oh shit, not her.
Wait, where did he go?
Nice.
I'm okay.
Did he die?
Yes, okay.
I'm just scared of one man.
I'm scared, I'm so...
I fear, I fear him.
Is he like, watching the backline too?
Like, yeah, like he's protecting his support, so I'm like...
That's why I can't flank, because he's like...
He's like, just guarding it.
So I'm just mowing down the tanks with my Psylocke, so that's fine.
One of my friends, he's like a pro player.
And his main hero pool is like Psylocke, and Psylocke, Starlord, and Bucky.
So he was telling me like, oh yeah, if you can't flank, you can just like, shred tanks frontline as Psylocke.
And I'm like, yippee!
Yeah, that makes sense.
Because like, you can get ult really fast too, if you just stand in the frontline.
I've had a Psylocke on my team where they were doing that, they weren't flanking at all.
They were just standing in the frontline, except they were dying all the time, and then they used their ult.
That was me for like, two deaths, and then I unlocked it.
I was just like, I figured it out.
They never figured it out the whole game.
That's why they're in gold!
That's sad.
I said, oh, I missed my right click.
I'm so bad with the right click.
This is good practice though, because usually you don't play DPS, right?
Yeah, usually.
Oh my god, of course!
Of course I fucking see you here.
Oh, but I got you.
I got you this time though.
I got him.
I fucking got him.
Oh, fucking, he had res, but I still got you.
We win this?
No?
Yeah, we do.
No, we don't, we don't, we don't, we don't.
We do not win this, because for some reason our rest of the team is still frontlining.
Yeah, I see them up there.
I think they're getting killed, maybe?
They're like in the backline, I don't know why.
Oh wait, wait a minute.
There you go.
Oh, that's right.
Nice, nice.
This guy's chasing you, watch out.
I know, I know he is.
They're all chasing me!
Okay, yeah, okay, I'm okay though.
Mantis, what are you doing?
Mantis, you're crazy!
You're so crazy!
He fucking was like running into...
You're so crazy, Mantis.
He's fucking frontlining with me.
You sure that's what you do?
But I don't trust a gold Mantis to be up here.
Maybe they're smurfing too.
They can't all be smurfs, Doobie!
There has to be real players here!
There has to be real players in gold!
Yeah, but you don't think they're also going against gold players though, you know?
Oh my god.
Oh, he's so low!
Oh my god, he actually got healed though.
I have ult soon.
I'm not gonna peek this because...
Oh, he's on Psylocke!
That's right, I'm better!
That's right!
No fear now.
I don't have fear now that he's on Psylocke.
Man, they're mad that if they switch to the same thing...
He's actually trying to mirror me.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I feel good though, like I'll play Venom and I feel like I'm doing really good and then the other tank switches to Venom.
Yeah, and you're just like, wait a minute, was I actually doing stuff?
Oh my god.
Oh, I forced ult, nice.
Nice.
Okay, Starlord, you should have waited a little start bit.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I fucked his ult.
They're so mad.
That's right!
Oh, and he goes GG!
Oh, you should have stayed, Bucky!
I was actually scared!
Now that you're not Bucky, I'm free to do whatever the fuck I want!
I'm gonna spawn camp.
Let's go.
I see you, Psylocke.
I see you over there.
Wait, actually, I don't.
Where did he go?
Wait, he disappeared.
Maybe he jumped off?
Wait, what the fuck, Wolverine?
The moment he swapped off of Bucky, I knew it was over for him.
GG.
Yeah, see, we told you guys.
First game was just warm-up.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, look!
Yippee!
Don't look at my accuracy, it's not real.
I was missing my right clicks and everything.
Wait, actually, what's the... I think I forgot to charge my mouse.
Oh, you have a wireless one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you use wireless?
No, I have a wired one.
I got a Zowie.
Oh, I use a G Pro Wireless.
I can't do wired, because it's like...
When you go wired... Have you ever tried wireless?
No, I never tried it.
It feels heavy, though.
Or isn't it?
No, no, no, no.
If you try a G Pro Wire... There's a Super Light.
If you try a Super Light...
Are you advertising to me right now?
Not sponsored, by the way.
But if you want to use my referral code...
Wait, really?
You have one?
No, I wish I could have a referral code from G...
It would be huge!
What was the company from Intel, right?
Logitech?
Yeah, Logitech.
We all blur together.
If it's sponsored by Logitech, that would be fucking crazy.
I've used G Pro Wireless for so long.
They're super light.
When I swapped from wired to wireless, it was lighter than my wired.
But they have weights and stuff that you can add.
Counterweight.
I don't know.
I think you'd like wireless.
When I went wired from wireless, I realized just how intrusive the wires were when I'm moving around.
I have a shitty $13 wireless mouse I use for my second PC.
It's so I can click on OBS stuff without changing my mouse.
That's so true.
Alright, let's see.
Triple DPS, let's go!
I don't really play.
I figured... I don't play Halo.
I don't know how to play it, but I figured I might as well.
Might as well try it out.
It seems like point and click.
I don't know.
I haven't played it either.
It seems like it though.
I'm also using a new crosshair because I got too lazy to use my actual...
Oh shit!
I hate Black Panther.
Someone break his knees right now.
Oh no, I don't know what counters Black Panther!
That's a DPS!
Oh!
I don't know.
Just leave it to me.
Chat, what counters Black Panther as a DPS player?
Alright, let me figure it out.
Because I don't know how to...
I wonder... Namor?
Oh, you're right, Namor.
I don't know how to play Namor.
But it can't be that hard.
I just put out turrets.
Yeah.
Aiming.
So it's like, just aim.
Oh man, I wish I could just aim.
I wish I have a Luna then.
Oh, I mean it's projectile, so...
That's right!
Try and dive me!
I have turrets!
That's fucking right!
I think Penny Parker is also anti-dive.
Yeah, she's anti-dive too.
Alright.
Try and dive me!
That's fucking right!
Oh, they double support ulted.
That's good for us.
Okay, I did not expect her to do that.
But alright, I'll slowly head over to the invisible world then.
Oh, we also double support ulted.
Okay.
Oh, are you okay?
Oh, you're dead.
No, I'm dead!
You're so dead.
You're definitely not...
You're definitely not okay.
That's fucking right!
He can't dive my supports, but...
Other than that, we're not doing anything.
I don't know...
Oh, I got two.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Get turret.
Get turreted.
Oh no.
No!
Oh, he got full HP.
Goddammit.
Well, we got the point.
There's a Panther still back here.
That's fine.
I got Starlord though.
I have turrets everywhere.
That's right!
Try and dive this!
Dive this!
Nice.
That's fucking right.
I'm just putting them on the ground.
I'm not even angling them.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, Jk.
That's right!
Get turreted!
He's just on the turret.
Oh yeah, you can't do anything!
That's fucking right!
Go back to Wakanda!
That's right!
Go back to Wakanda where you belong.
Oh, I got the ult.
I'm just like, random.
Oh, he actually is getting hit by the...
Nah, he got out.
Yeah, he was like 1 HP.
He was actually 1 HP.
Oh, do we have...
I don't know where people are, but I'm assuming that my things are doing stuff, honestly.
Where is Wakanda?
Where is he?
I have my turret just chilling.
I don't know where he is.
I'm a little worried.
I was going to say, isn't this Wakanda, but this is not Wakanda.
No, this is not Wakanda!
He's not back home yet.
Oh, I don't know where you have support ults for this.
Oh, I should have saved it.
What the hell?
What is he doing here?
Oh, no!
No!
I think I'm going to switch to Venom 2.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We still have one more fight.
Alright, okay.
I got Venomed hard.
I wasted my ult because I thought we were going to win it for some reason.
I don't know why I thought we were going to win.
It was very obvious.
We were not winning that fight.
I don't know.
I was just...
We have to... We're not getting that.
I get melted.
It's like the only tank.
No!
Especially with Boondight.
I shut down their Black Panther, so we couldn't do anything after that.
Now, we just need the rest of our team to do stuff.
I'm trying!
No, no, not you.
You're our only tank.
It's never the solo tank's fault.
It's the other players.
It's never the solo tank.
We could really use another tank.
Yeah, maybe someone will switch.
Maybe more for a Panther counter.
Yeah, I'm like... I nearly got... I got rid of... I got rid of Panther for so long because of me.
Yeah, I think it helped too.
Yeah, me and you, we just... They just had... I mean, they're literally running meta.
Fucking nerds.
Why are you running meta in gold?
Is that the meta?
Yeah, Mag, Strange is meta.
All I'm saying is you're still Track Force, Mag, Strange in gold and you're not climbing.
It's not the meta problem.
It's not.
You're running meta wrong and you might as well just play off meta.
It's not, yeah.
I just think you might as well play off meta if you can't... you can't even climb meta.
Yeah, we got a Megiddo now.
We're meta too.
Oh my gosh, whoops.
I threw a little bit.
I used my shift, but that's a miss.
I have Venom as well.
Oh, they're running Venom now.
Yeah, I switched it up.
I think I mismapped New Harker's.
Maybe you're trying to...
Oh, that's fine.
Disappear.
That's fine.
Oh, you can't do anything about it.
Okay, like, please one flanker at a time.
Are they diving together at all?
Yeah, I got both Panther and Venom on my ass just then.
I was like, okay guys, one at a time if you're gonna flank me.
I have no idea how to use the Penny Parker ult.
Yeah, you just use it on...
What is this?
Oh.
You just use it on the point.
I don't know.
This is my very first time playing anymore, by the way.
I'm like a little...
Isn't he fun?
Hey, nice.
I got a kill.
Alright, yeah.
Come on.
Go for the turret.
He's like... he's like weird to aim a little, though.
I would admit.
Oh, yeah.
It's not hitscan.
It's like...
Yeah, it's projectile.
It has drop-off, too.
Yeah.
Wait, it has drop-off?
I didn't even know that.
Yeah.
Now I do.
It's pretty far, though, I think.
Like, I'm so disorienting trying to aim with it.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Ah, the ult!
I ulted it, though, but I don't know if it does anything.
You knocked Strange down.
That helped.
It's just the Moon Knight was above just spamming.
I got him off.
It's fine.
I'm basically shutting him... how does he... Black Panther get killed?
I've been, like, shutting him down.
Yeah, I haven't seen him.
Yeah, he's just like, where are you?
Maybe I'll just play next to my support, just in case.
But our support positions so weirdly sometimes.
They, like, position in them, and I was like, I don't want to be in them.
Really?
Yeah, they're, like, frontlining sometimes.
And I'm like, well, I don't want to be there.
Yeah.
Honestly.
Oh, the Moon Knight's one.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, I got him.
I got... oh, wait, I got Moon Knight.
Nice.
I'm putting my turrets at the weirdest spots, but somehow it's working?
Because I think it's just the ELO?
Yeah, yeah.
They don't shoot at it.
They're, like, uh...
Yeah, like, these are pretty bad spots, not gonna lie.
Like, but I'll take those.
I know as a gold player myself, I'll see them and I'll just walk by them and hope somebody else deals with them.
Yeah, some of them don't even shoot the Angs too, which I've noticed.
You know, that I try to shoot, but I can't.
No!
No, not the Moon!
All the ults.
No!
Okay, I guess I'll stay on there.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I have my ult.
Yeah, just wait until everybody's up.
Oh my god, I'm coming over.
I'm walking.
Oh, nice Conchu, but, like, I don't know if we should use it now because we're not here, but that's alright.
Yeah, we'll be the only one there.
I was like, alright, I mean, that's cool.
That's cool, but, you know, we're all...
I don't know about that.
And solo.
Oh no!
I went in to try to help the Moon Knight.
I should've waited.
Okay, look.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
At this point, I'll just use it here.
I'm still there on the point, but, like, I don't feel so good.
What is that line from the movie?
Like, I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good.
Bro, I just saw the mech behind me watching me.
I was just like, what are you doing?
Oh my god.
I tried to stall.
The Moon.
It's okay.
It's not our fault.
It's not us.
It's never us.
We're streamers.
It's never the streamer's fault.
He mates.
Yeah, exactly.
I literally was, like, on the point and I turned around and see our mech just watching me out off of point.
I'm just like, okay, alright, that's...
I'm okay with that, I guess.
Maybe I shouldn't play Penny Parker on, like, control point.
Maybe it's too... I don't know.
Sometimes it works, but sometimes not so much.
Well, it should work because we were playing against Black Panther.
It's just our team wasn't shutting down Panther enough.
I played Namor and then the Panther literally just stopped trying to dive me.
Like, he ran away from me all of a sudden.
He gave up.
Yeah, he gave up because I had, like, turrets with me.
But I guess, like, he just went after my support players because I didn't know where the fuck they went.
I was like, where's my support?
Yeah, I didn't really see them, but maybe it's my fault because I didn't turn around.
As a tank, you don't really see them often, too, because you're just...
You're always, like, you know, you just have to look at the front.
What's this?
Oh, this is the newest map.
I heard... I was gonna try Storm.
This is a good Penny Parker map.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I have no idea because, like I said, I never see Penny.
I never see Penny in my...
I mean, this is supposed to be New York, so it's like Spider-Man.
That's true.
That's where Spider-Man lives.
Penny Parker lives in Japan, doesn't she?
I mean, you know, it's another city.
One concrete jungle to another.
You're right, you're right.
Tokyo is also a city.
Tokyo, New York is basically the same, right?
I mean, New York is, like, kind of stuck in the past, but...
Yeah, they're pretty similar.
Alright, I am... I hope I get healed.
I hope.
That's really all I hope for.
Alright, I'm on damage.
Oh, I got the heal.
I got heal off.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I was not expecting it.
I was not exp... What the fuck?
No, not another...
Oh my god, okay.
No, I don't... I don't want to go no more!
God damn it.
Oh, I don't want to go no more, though.
He's gone!
He has a big whale.
It's so cool.
I just don't know his projectile enough to, like, go him.
Man, there's a Moon Knight in every single game.
It's so annoying.
Oh, wait, are you doing Moon Knight grid?
Oh, I hate that.
I hate that comp.
Oh, I guess I'll learn no more.
I guess it's time.
Why do we have, like... Don't have a Luna... The moment I play no more, we don't have a Luna player.
Yeah, that's really useful.
Shoot the Ankh!
Their Ankh, where is it?
No, it's... I got it.
I got it.
Yeah, we got one.
Nice.
Nice, I have turrets.
Come on, you should be dead.
There we go, we did it.
It was just that easy.
Okay, I'm, like, a little scared to go up... like, group up because of the fact that they have a Groot.
Yeah, a Groot and Moon Knight.
That's basically it.
Okay.
I have turrets on me, but I'm trying to break the walls right now.
I got one guy.
Nice!
I got Black Panther.
I got DP.
He is so looking for ult.
Oh my god, look at him.
He's just... he's looking for it.
Oh, I'm trying to break this.
I'm trying to break this.
I'm the only one trying to break this stupid tree!
I'm walking around.
I spent, like, 20 seconds just trying to break the wall.
That was a mistake.
I should not have done that.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm not okay right now, but that's fine.
Where is she?
No, it was right there!
I was on it!
Where are you?
There you go, I got him.
Oh, nice.
I got him.
Don't worry, the evil has been defeated.
I sent him back to Wakanda.
It's fine.
Please!
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Oh, please, I'm just a little baby.
Oh, there it is!
Goodbye, everybody!
Goodbye!
I leave!
The wombo combo.
I got mine killed, though.
That's pretty cool.
That's right!
Oh, you're scared!
You're so scared.
I have turrets.
That's goddamn right.
Okay, but like... Oh my god, that's alright.
We don't have healers right now, but that's fine.
I'm just gonna stay here.
They're on their way.
They're behind me.
Oh, that was unlucky.
Both are...
Oh, I thought they were closer.
Oh wait, no, I did.
I knocked him down.
You knocked one, I think.
Do you know Marvel characters and stuff a little bit?
Yeah, but I'm more of a DC fan, though.
I just never really liked the Marvel Cinematic... I didn't like the movie cinematic universe that much.
I don't know if you think so, but it got way too formulaic at one point.
I haven't really watched them.
I didn't watch any of the Marvel movies except for Guardians of the Galaxy.
Oh yeah, I like Guardians of the Galaxy.
I think it's the music that makes it.
Yeah, it's the music and it's like, you know the director, James Gunn?
Yeah.
Yeah, I love his stuff.
His stuff is so different from... I mean, you can say that they're formulaic now because he has the formula, but it's just different from Marvel and stuff.
Have you seen his newest anime thing, the Creature Commandos?
I don't think so.
What is that?
Oh my god, it's like he's rebooting DC now.
Now he's working for DC.
He's doing really well.
He did really well with Marvel, so DC hired him.
And it's basically like, you know the Suicide Squad?
They're rebooting the Suicide Squad, but animated for him.
Honestly, I highly recommend it.
I am the only DPS that has more kills than the rest of the DPS!
You can't say it was me!
And all I've been doing is just...
I think it's just that we don't have another... I don't know, maybe it's because I don't play any other tanks.
I can play Strange for you, but then they'll have to complain even more.
Like, they can't complain about DPS when I'm literally the only one that's doing something for us.
The hello melts me so bad.
Yeah,
I can't freaking live right now.
That's fine.
It's fine, because every win we get, we get... Guys, please touch it.
Please touch it, guys.
No!
It's okay, we're a little too good.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh my god, this hella has 24 kills.
I wish I could play a character that we're not forced to do anti-dive.
Yeah, I mean, now that we're on attack...
That's true, that's true.
That's true.
Just let our team die.
When you please hit attack, it's just soloing.
How can we hit anything?
Oh, wait, wait.
You can play DPS now.
Oh, you can play Namor!
You can play Namor!
Nevermind.
I mean, one take is viable, right?
Yeah, that's fine.
You should play Namor.
You know how to play Namor.
I was learning as we go.
I was literally learning how to play as we go.
This is like my second game on Namor.
But yeah, no, you should check out... I think you'd like Creature Commandos.
It's actually a really good animation.
Because if you like Guardians of the Galaxy, you might like Creature Commandos.
Is it out already?
I thought it was just the...
Yeah, the full series ended like last week.
Oh, okay.
Wait, on what?
Is it like a Disney?
Not Disney, no.
It's on...
Paramount?
I think so.
I think?
I don't remember where it was on.
But I personally really like it.
There's like... Okay, so like, you know, there's like screenshots, like GIFs of it everywhere.
But GI... I think you'd like the character GI Robot, I think.
GI Robot?
GI Robot.
Oh, wait, is that the one?
I think I've seen it.
On Twitter?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where it comes from.
That's where GI comes from.
I like the music that people were... I don't know if it's like wind up something boy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think like... Wait, have you ever watched the Peacemaker with John Cena?
Oh, no, I haven't seen it.
Oh, I think... Oh, you'd like that too then.
Because it's also James Gunn.
Oh, okay.
Because I think you just really... I think you just like James Gunn.
Like James Gunn directed things?
Maybe, yeah, maybe.
Because he has like... His personal style is like destroy the...
Try...
Okay, I'm gonna switch.
Where are you gonna switch to?
Okay, if you're gonna do that, I'm gonna... If we have a rocket anyway, so...
I'll just play Call of Duty.
Oh, Lunis, that was the one in the back.
Nevermind, shut up.
They were all so low.
I'm just gonna... They were all so low.
And we have...
Nice.
Yeah, I think you'd like Peacemaker too.
What are your favorite shows then?
What do you tend to watch?
I watch The Voice.
I watch Invincible.
Invincible.
They're not my favorite, but I enjoyed watching them, I guess.
What are your favorite shows in general?
Like, not just superheroes.
I've just been watching anime.
I don't know.
I don't watch that much TV, I guess, or shows.
I'm different.
It's because for me, I just don't have... I'm dead.
I heard the Moon Knight.
I was like, there's no way I'm living through that.
For me, I just don't have time to watch anime, because you know how it's like...
In anime, you have to read the subtitles.
Oh, yeah.
You can't read?
No, I feel like...
Yeah, no, you're right.
No, you're right.
You're right.
I can't read.
But I'm also like... You know how I'm a workaholic, so I get lazy.
Not lazy, but like...
Wait, where?
Oh, you like to do stuff while watching shows, right?
Yeah, I like to do stuff while watching.
That makes sense.
Yes, I feel like I'm like not being productive.
Wait, we capped it?
Where the fuck was there...
Somehow...
I don't even see anyone alive.
I was not even...
How the fuck did we cap it?
That's crazy.
I think this... I think the enemy team is stacking.
They're like way too coordinated, you know?
Oh, that makes sense.
Yeah, maybe it's a four stack or something.
Yeah, no, this team feels way too...
Oh, no.
This is where I die.
Oh, that's cool.
Hey, I'm in it too.
He has nowhere to... He has nowhere to throw it, but like...
He's gonna throw us into his team.
No!
I should've shot the Jeff instead of Luna.
Yeah, she was keeping him up.
Yeah.
I'm coming over.
I like how my chat was like, just learn Japanese.
Oh, yeah, let's meet...
That's a lot of work.
Let me just learn another language real quick.
You can do the dub version for some of them.
Yeah, but it's not the same, I feel like.
Yeah, it's just not the same.
Jesus Christ, where is this stupid Black Panther?
Alright, I'm just gonna wait until...
I hate you.
Get me out of here.
Do you think DC will make a game like this?
DC?
They tried.
They did?
I feel like they have to like...
Oh my gosh, I forgot.
I have my fucking glasses toggled on.
So every time I press 1, I wear my glasses.
But like, I feel like...
I don't know.
They tried to make games for it.
They tried to make live service games.
You know, the Suicide Squad one?
No, I didn't know they had one.
There's a reason why you don't know.
It was like a live service game.
So it was like...
It's apparently, you know, like the Batman Gotham City.
Like those games and stuff.
Basically, it's like...
It's not...
Like, everybody loves the Gotham City and the Dark Knight and all that for the game.
But like, the...
So like, it was supposed to be the sequel to the Batman series.
But then it's really, really, really, really, really...
Like Dark Knight, yeah, it's really, really bad.
I'm not gonna die.
Oh, now we have Luna!
Okay.
I get so melted.
Yeah, and then...
The game was supposed to have like a long story.
And it was gonna be like a super long, like...
Lots of DLCs and stuff.
Season passes and things like that.
And then like, it literally just ended in...
I don't think he knows that...
That like, you know...
You can't eat me.
I don't think he knows that.
Ah, fucking hell.
I like, went back into it.
That's it!
I almost went back into it.
So wait, what type of game was it?
It was a live service game.
So you know like, there's like a progression.
I don't know how to explain it.
But it's basically like, Assassin's Creed type deal.
So it's like a progress...
You know, you find things, there's missions.
But it's just not good.
Oh no, it's not good?
Looter Shooter.
Yeah, it's a Looter Shooter type deal.
But there's like, battle pass and stuff like that.
And it literally died...
It died in a year.
And then they...
Cause like, the biggest thing that people hated...
Was the fact that like, they killed off Batman.
On a series about...
That was supposed to be like, the sequel to like, Arkham Knight.
And it was so fucked up because like...
You know like, the voice actor for Batman.
It was considered to be one of his last roles.
So like...
Because...
So they were like, you just killed him off?
And then, people found out...
Like, last week, cause the game ended.
They were like, JK, they were just clones.
Ah...
What?
Yeah, cause they killed off the entire Justice League.
And they're like, JK, they didn't actually...
They were just clones.
So they did it just to like, get...
Like, just to bait people and get engagement.
Which is pretty fucked.
That just sounds like something they came up with afterwards, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Be like, no guys, don't be upset.
No, no, stop, don't be upset.
They're not actually dead.
See, look.
Somebody said spoilers, but I'm pretty sure...
You can't play it anymore, right?
Or can you still play it?
You can still play it, but like...
If you're like, mad about spoilers...
On a game that's bad, like...
I don't think you should be mad about spoilers.
That game was absolutely terrible.
They're literally shutting it down in a few months too.
Oh, okay.
What?
You still have time to play it?
Yeah, guys.
Guys, you wanna spend $40?
Oh, yeah, oh.
Yeah, it's like $40+, because it's a AAA game.
So it's like $40+.
And then it'll just close down and you'll lose your money.
Yep, yeah.
Yes, that's why people were mad that it was live service.
Because they're like, why are you...
Like, it's gonna close down because of the reception.
Yeah.
It's just like, at least it's not like Concord.
Concord?
Did you play that?
I really wanted to.
I wanted to play it so badly.
They shut it...
Because I think I was like...
I think I was like away or something.
So I couldn't play it.
I was like on a trip or something.
Maybe I was like rehearsing for the concert.
Oh, yeah.
So I couldn't check it.
And then the moment they shut it down, it was too late.
I was gone.
There's a Wolverine.
He's gonna kidnap.
Use his passive though.
Oh, but it doesn't matter.
Our guy's fucking dead.
I'm on it.
I got her.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Wait, I know he does that passive.
Oh, no, he's dead.
He's actually...
He's getting healed.
That's illegal.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we still have these points.
Why is Rocket?
I'm just fucking playing.
Yeah, you have the blue thingy.
Oh, wait.
I have all the red.
Oh, wait, all the DPS.
Oh, my God.
Mr. Fantastic, come on.
Go get him.
Go.
I got him.
It's time we capped it.
There you go.
He's haha'ing now.
Haha!
Wait, actually, I can force something out.
There you go.
I forced a support ult.
Haha!
Oh, nice.
Oh, I'm dead though.
He's so bad.
I'm dead.
She died from it because Mantis ult is...
The more people are grouped up, the more you get healed.
But everybody ran from her.
Also, I heard for Psylocke's ult, you can outlive it if all your team is jumping it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you stack up, there's a potential to live for it.
Oh, oh.
He's saying that ult.
That's right.
What you gonna do to me?
You have no more abilities here.
Let me farm ults off you.
Oh, disappear.
Wait, I hear somebody on the outside.
Oh, there you are.
There's some magic, I guess.
Oh, I fucked up.
Yeah, I got the Punisher though.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm alive.
Oh, you're so low.
I'm so healthy.
I'm okay.
You can play this game with controller, can't you?
You can, but there's no aim assist.
Yeah.
You can.
It's just like, there's actually a pro player that plays on controller.
Oh.
Yeah, he's actually crazy.
I'm scared of him.
I mean, it makes sense.
Like, if there's Call of Duty play or something and it just feels more natural.
Yeah.
No, he was an Overwatch controller player.
That's what makes him crazy.
What did he play?
He was a tank player.
He plays tank.
Oh, okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm invisible and I'm alive.
I don't know what I'm cooking.
Aha!
Give me your ult.
Give me your ult charge.
Judge!
Jury!
Executioner!
He was trying to...
Oh, shit.
He was trying to find me.
Oh, I used it.
The Punisher.
I went invisible in front of him and he instantly 180'd.
He was like...
He thought I was behind him.
And I just thought I was looking at him in front of me.
He was like, oh my god, bro, where did she go?
And I just stood in front of him.
It's like the mind...
Mind games.
Yeah, mind games.
Yeah, I'm here to fuck with him.
Mental warfare.
The mental warfare.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What games have you been mostly playing lately, Doobie?
Roblox.
What are your favorite Roblox games?
Just the dress-up one and the cake one.
Wait, you just spend your time playing either of those?
Yeah.
No, I was playing Counter-Strike.
On Roblox?
Yesterday.
Or like regular.
No, not on Roblox.
Just regular CS2.
The real one.
I was like, wait, on Roblox?
No, no.
Crazy.
There's... have you seen... I guess it's called Murky Divers or something?
Oh, Murky... yeah, I've always wanted to try Murky Divers.
Oh, has it been out for a while?
I thought it just came out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's been out.
They've been like... there was like a beta for it.
Oh.
Why are you trying to...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Thank you.
I got... I got stuck.
I'm just gonna be on point real quick.
Fast.
Yeah.
Wait, isn't that... that's multiplayer, right?
Yeah, yeah, there's like eight... up to eight people can play.
Whoa.
Yeah, I never played it.
I heard it's like... it's like a little bit like horror-esque type deal too, right?
Yeah.
Okay, break this thing.
I think it's kind of like Weeple Company a little bit.
Oh.
Maybe?
I don't know.
I've always wanted to play it.
Or it's like... I heard it's really fun.
Because like you're like... you have the potential to die in the water type deal.
Yeah.
What are you trying to do, Penny?
Somebody said you were lagging, but I think it passed already.
It just happens with internet.
Oh, yeah.
Did you fix your internet?
Um... kind of.
I think something was wrong with the cables, but...
Oh, is it a cable thing?
Sometimes it still drops.
Yeah, I think so.
Not my cables.
It's like, I guess...
It's just like ISP cables type deal.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that makes sense.
Oh, I didn't actually press E.
That's alright.
I just got like a satellite backup internet, but I haven't...
Oh my god!
He accidentally gripped me!
He wasn't even trying!
Oh my god, he wasn't even...
Sorry, I got like gripped while I was trying to ult.
Gripped?
Yeah, yeah.
The bucket like fucking held me and I was just like, oh my god.
He gripped you firmly?
Yeah, he gripped me hard and I was like, whoa!
Whoa,
I did not expect that.
Oh, we win this anyway.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Came back and we won.
Look at that.
Insane heals.
Oh, they're talking about you!
I... I... I don't know about that.
They're talking about you!
I ran away from most of them.
What else?
What else were they talking about?
Oh, he... There's nobody on point.
You know, it's the... It's the thought that counts, you know?
What the fuck?
Strange, why were you watching?
The strange was just watching me 1v1 Penny.
He's like, you... you can deal with it.
You're the DPS.
Yeah, that's why I thought the strange was watching me.
I was like, shoot him!
Why you don't shoot him?
I just...
Wait, he gave up.
Yeah, or maybe their mouth died.
I just thought the Psylocke gave up.
Probably.
Did we win?
Yeah, we did.
We got back all the points we lost in two games... in one game.
Yeah, ranked back up.
So it's like true tank, me.
Respecting the 1v1.
Yeah, yeah.
I know, but isn't it like...
You're going into tank, not another DPS.
Yeah, yeah.
But he wanted the tank to have his 1v1.
I'm like, that's fucked up.
That's fucked up, bro.
Our Mr. Fantastic never died.
That's crazy.
Wait, I also never died.
Okay, but you're a rock.
Yeah, I got out really fast.
You can climb, you can dash, you can jump, you can glide.
Maybe it should be a Rocket 1 trick, because we just won.
I think there's a correlation there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't go to the dark side.
No, we don't need...
Doobie, no, we don't need more Rocket Baits, Doobie.
We have matching banners.
Oh my god.
They do, they're 3-stacking.
DC is better.
Oh, is that somebody's enemy?
Yeah, the enemy team.
What is that?
Their name is literally, DC is better.
The Holy Bible.
Oh my god, we have the Holy Bible on our team.
Is there... is somebody talking in-game?
Yeah, there is.
Oh, okay.
That was a fail.
I was hearing voices.
I don't even know.
I don't like how you don't know who he's talking to.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's bugged, like it doesn't show it at all.
Yeah, it doesn't show.
I think it's RSXGod.
I literally muted the first person I saw, and now it's quiet.
Now it's quiet.
I have it really low, so I just hear...
It's like the Snoopy characters.
The Snoopy adults are like...
Alright, well if any... nobody's gonna... okay.
I guess I'll play support.
It's back to Luna, jail we go.
Yay!
Yippee!
I'll never die!
I mean, you like playing her, right?
I do, I do.
I love playing Luna, Snow.
I saw your schedule art.
Oh yeah, the Luna, Snow cosplay.
The one time I had boobs, like...
Oh yeah, I saw that.
I'm like, god damn, that's a bare boob.
I was like, no, wait a second, I have to do a double take.
Don't worry, it's not padded, guys.
It's not a push-up, it's not padded, it's 100% legit.
Oh yeah, I wanted to ask.
Well, I mean, it's okay, you don't have to answer, but...
Cause you showed your 3D during the concert.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But are you gonna have like an official 3D debut?
Cause I haven't seen you use it.
Oh yeah, yeah, that's why I've been waiting for the official.
I've been like scouting out studios for it too.
Cause like, people are like, oh, do you have any plans?
I have no plans yet.
But no actual concrete plans and stuff.
I really, really want to do an actual official debut.
Yeah, you should, that'd be cool.
So then I can actually use the model for stuff, like...
Like shorts and things?
Yeah, yeah, like your dancing shorts, that's so fun.
Then you were doing all those like dancing shorts and with the chibi and the main model.
Yeah, I could see you doing some cute ones, like the cat one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then the...
Actually, I was gonna say, you guys could probably reuse like some of the concert stuff.
Yeah, yeah, no, we were planning to, yeah.
Sorry I spoiled it.
No, no, I told my chat cause like, one of the things we recorded was literally like me doing Soldier Boy.
Nice.
I wanted to do it at the concert, but Min was like, we are not doing Soldier Boy at the concert.
You recorded a whole song?
No, it was like we were choosing our setlist and the one thing I wanted was Soldier Boy.
But because I can't... Oh, I was 97, I was not paying attention.
That's fine.
Wait, oh, she destroyed the rez.
I was like, what?
Yeah.
I tried to take it down before she destroyed it, but I guess it didn't let me.
Yeah, but I have a Soldier Boy short.
I told my chat about it too.
I was like, Soldier Boy...
We also did Ganon style.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, cause you guys had the glasses, right?
Like, sunglasses?
Or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, our DPS is...
I don't think they're enjoying the Amplifier.
Okay.
Oh, we could technically mow her down, but like...
Technically our Iron Man could do something, but he's not going.
He's just flying around.
He could have ulted her, but...
Oh, now there's the ult.
Alright.
I'm alive.
Thank god.
I'm gonna... I guess I'll kill him for us too.
We haven't got the point yet, though.
Yeah, no, we didn't.
Oh, we're running triple support.
Oh, we got it, we got it.
Who decided to not play DPS?
Iron Man?
No.
No, no, no.
Oh, wait, no, it's Iron...
I can do triple support after this, actually.
That's fine.
I'm practically being DPS right now.
As Luna.
I think even if you play support, and we have like triple, you'll still do way more damage than a lot of the other supports either on our team or on their team.
My chat was like, dude, keep your survival magneto up.
This is... I'm not afraid of gold magnetos.
The worst is when you hear Iron Man ult and he's like right behind you.
Oh, yeah, I hate that.
I've had that happen to me so many times.
That shit...
Oh, shit.
Holy Bible.
Oops.
I should have helped you.
No idea why.
Shit.
Yeah, I can live this, so I'm just gonna...
Oh, tank, why did you just, you know, decide to...
Alright, here we go.
Aww, I'm invisible.
Why is I...
What?
He doesn't know how to get up!
I'm... Kurt doesn't know how to get up!
He's stuck!
He doesn't know how to...
I'm watching you, I'm watching you!
Oh, my God!
Kurt didn't know how to...
Kurt!
He's here, he's here, he's here.
He didn't know how to get up!
What was I watching?
I watched him walk around the...
Oh, the bottom.
He was stuck in... He was stuck on the bottom for so long!
He switched to Hulk.
I think maybe he feels bad, cause he...
I don't know, maybe he thought he could jump up somehow.
Have you ever played, um, Paladins?
Paladins?
Oh, yeah, I played a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's, like, a character that's kind of like Groot, but he swings like Spider-Man.
Yeah, yeah.
That'd be cool if Groot in this game had, like, a kind of, like, a short swing, not crazy like Venom.
Yeah, yeah, and just, like, swing back up.
To be fair, that would be so scary, too.
That would be so fucking scary.
Yeah, if I just see a giant...
He's already kind of OP or something.
Yeah, yeah, if I just see a giant tree just swinging in and be like, I am Groot, I'd be so scared.
Alright.
Oh, now we don't have any support.
Wait, what?
Where did our other support go?
Oh, we have, we have Adam Warlock.
This should be good.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that'd be good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh, hey, I can do this.
I can do this.
Nice.
Round of bullshit, let's go.
Let's go.
Alright, I don't like our Iron Man.
He's, he's, he might be, like, an ace, but I don't like him.
But, like, I don't like the stuff he's doing.
He's just doing his own thing.
Oh, my God.
Alright, that's fine.
Us against the world.
Oh, my God, he is.
Come on, Indian team, I know you want to go low-key.
Come on.
Oh, my God, I almost have ult.
Alright, no.
Liv, please.
I almost have ult.
Please.
Jesus Christ, I should have put it further up.
I should have...
That literally got the freest ult ever, and I could have...
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, no.
Goodbye.
Oh, nice.
Wait, why did she stack it here?
Stack it on the point!
Oh, my God!
Sorry!
Oh, my God, Doobie, you gotta stack it on the point, Doobie!
I panicked!
I'm a tank main now, I don't play support.
Okay, like, as Cloak, you're so strong.
Your ult is so strong that if you stack it...
If you stack it on point and just do it twice, you... Oh, my God, nice.
You literally kill everybody.
Like, nobody dies.
That's how I used to use the ult, but then people told me that you have to use it more, like, defensively for the team since it heals.
Yeah, yeah, like, uh... Yeah, yeah, when you use it defensively, just go up.
Go up and then go back once and then, like, you live.
Because she got the buff where, like, nobody dies now.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, like, that was old Cloak.
That was, like, Season 0 Cloak.
Season 1 Cloak is, like, crazy broken.
So, like, nobody can die.
Like, you live through a Punisher ult and a Cloak ult now.
That's how crazy broken she is.
Okay.
Sorry, my ring toxicity almost got out.
Why are you yelling at me?
It's not yelling, chat.
It's called character build.
She's building character.
I'm getting free coaching.
Yeah.
Does our Groot have... No.
Okay.
Let's do double moons, I guess.
So they'll think it's their moon.
I almost forget to use my E.
I haven't played Cl- uh...
It's not fair.
You have a fucking...
You have a snowflake!
It's actually crazy.
We haven't bumped into a Luna player, too, in our own game.
On our team?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, Luna is such a...
Such a good... Like, the one...
Like, they all play... Everybody plays...
The other support players, they play everything but Luna.
Yeah.
I don't... I don't know.
I don't like playing her.
Like, she feels...
Like, I miss my shots, I guess.
Yeah, she has a high skill ceiling.
Because you have to require aim and stuff.
But it's just weird because, like, the enemy team has Cloak.
Yeah.
And not Luna.
Not Cloak.
Luna.
Luna, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I still have... Oh, my God.
I have the most damage.
It's okay.
Nice.
We're just... We're still warming up, guys.
We're still...
Yeah.
Guys, we're still warming up.
It's okay.
It's like we win-lose, win-lose, win-lose.
Oh, that's, like, the worst part.
That's the worst part.
I once had, like... I once had, like, an actual Zebra record.
For, like, the entire page was just win-lose, win-lose, win-lose, win-lose.
Like, I was going crazy.
I was crashing out.
What rank was that?
It was... Yeah, it was one above all.
It was literally win-lose, win-lose, win-lose, win-lose.
And I was playing with, like... I was trioing, too.
So, it was crazy.
Like, we would have the easiest games when we're winning.
And the most fucked-up, hard-ass games when we lose.
I was like, why can't we have it twice?
I think I would give up.
Oh, no.
I was crashing out.
The only reason why I kept going was because...
Was because I had to end in top 500, so I, like, was forced to keep going.
I just... I had to...
I had to get in.
You played, like, nine hours or something?
I played for, like...
I played for, like, 14 plus hours.
And, like, this was off-stream, too.
This was off-stream.
And I was just, like...
I was so desperate.
I was just, like...
I was literally, like...
Because, like, I thought I was safe.
You know, like, when you think you're safe, but you're not.
And then you...
Because I got close to... I thought I was in a safe area.
And so, I was like, okay, I don't have to play for the next three...
The next couple of days.
And then, oh my god, we just have DPS players.
That's good, that's good.
So, we both played for...
Yeah, yeah.
And then...
And then, like, on the last day, we found out that I was absolutely not safe.
So, I just had to...
I just...
Grind.
I just kept...
And then, the worst part was afterwards.
I had to...
I had to, like...
I had a stream.
And I had to go to the passport office to take a picture.
And get my passport renewed.
And I picked up the passport, like, two days ago.
And, um...
The photo is, like, post-Marvel...
And that's gonna be...
Yeah, like, dark circles under your eyes.
Yeah, that's gonna be my photo for the next ten years.
And it's, like, post-Marvel rivals rank grind.
I mean, it's a fun time.
Now you'll remember the good memories forever.
Yeah, yeah.
Great memories.
My, like...
Okay, let's see.
I got my passport photo taken at, like, a...
Like, a pharmacy.
Yeah.
And they just had a really shitty digital camera.
Like, one of those snapshot ones.
From, like, 2003.
Uh-huh.
And the picture came out so bad.
Whenever I go through airport security, they're like, Are you sure this is you?
Is this you?
And I'm like, yeah, it was a really bad picture.
And they're, like, laughing at my picture.
They're just like...
Thanks.
How long do you have to keep your passport for?
Yeah, it's also ten years.
That's your legacy.
That's gonna be...
Maybe I'll lose it.
You'll lose it and be like, whoops, gotta renew my passport.
Alright, yes.
Oh my god.
I remember back then.
Back then, you can, like, Photoshop your photos too.
Back then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think there's, like, some countries where they let you put, like, beauty filters on your passport.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so, like, when I got my passport renewed out of country, they do not have, like, photo regulations.
Because it's, like, you know, it's just the embassy that's doing your photo.
So they didn't care.
And then, like, I think, like, my mom did, like, a beauty filter for her photo.
Because they didn't care.
I already had my own.
I was not paying attention.
Nice.
Look at that.
Wow, this game is so easy.
Hey, Rocket Raccoon.
What you doing outside your home, Rocket Raccoon?
What you doing outside?
Alright.
Oh, he missed.
He actually missed.
Alright, go kill him.
Oh, no.
Go kill them.
Yes, go, Magneto, go!
There's somebody behind.
Oh.
Who is it?
Who's behind?
Oh, no.
I got him.
I got him for you.
Nice.
You might have died, but I got revenge for you.
That's fine.
Our Mag is so healthy.
Look, he's alive.
Oh, here there's a thing where, um, if you have, like, a religion, like, you can take a picture for your passport or ID.
Like, wearing whatever your religion thing is.
Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, some people wear, like, a colander to take their picture.
Because they're, like, apostapharian.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, like the spaghetti monster.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, like, is that actually a registered religion?
Yeah, you can have one official.
Wait, really?
I thought it was, like, a meme.
I didn't realize it was an actual registered religion.
I mean, I don't know if they check.
Maybe it does have to be registered.
Probably chat knows.
I feel like, apparently, it's not hard to start a church or religion.
Unless you try to start a VTuber.
Like, you just need a place of worship.
I watched a video of a guy that started a religion for his, like, a church slash religion for a YouTube channel.
And also for, like, and it's, like, recognized by the government and stuff and, like, you can get, like, tax breaks and stuff from it.
Which is absolutely crazy that you can get tax breaks from a random religion you start.
Yeah.
That's why most people do it now, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, like, for tax reasons, yeah.
And then, like...
Wow, we should totally start...
Oh my god, we should start a YouTube... a VTuber.
Definitely very legal in my eyes.
I mean, we already take donations, so...
Yeah, exactly.
Like, you can say SuperChat is, like, a donation to the church, you know?
Like...
I think we are not gonna be okay.
Actually, we are.
I'm scheming.
Rocket Raccoon, what are you doing, Rocket Raccoon?
You're throwing.
What are you... Oh, your Bucky saved your life.
Let's finally win it.
Alright, so basically...
To start a religion, you just... you literally just need a place of worship.
And then, like, a place of worship and, like, people have... you have to give, like, service.
Like, sermons and stuff at the place of worship.
And then, that's how you make a religion.
And you just apply... like, do, like, an application and the government just has to recognize it.
And then, a YouTuber did it and he just... he was, like... he did it for, like, one week and disbanded it after that.
Oh, just to see if he could do it.
Yeah, see if he could do it.
Yeah, and it got recognized by the...
It got recognized by the British government.
I pranked the government.
So, if all the VTubers work together and, like, buy a church, we can make a religion.
And then, we'll run it as a venue for a virtual concert.
Yeah, exactly.
And then, like, our sermons will be, like, virtual concerts and, like...
We can put a laptop, like, a giant screen and then, like, we can live stream into it and those are our sermons.
And we just do it every Sunday.
We can make it for a day.
It doesn't have to be a Sunday.
Oh, true.
It doesn't have to be a Sunday, but then...
Saturday night party.
We can make it, like... We can make it, like, a Monday and then say... and then make it, like, a religious holiday, so, like, the...
So, your work... you can be like, I'm sorry, I have to go to... I have to go to church on Monday.
We have a special event.
There you go.
We're cookie right now.
Write it down, guys.
Write it down.
My next project, I'm gonna start a church.
I'm gonna get sponsored.
I believe it if you say it.
I'm gonna get spon... I'm gonna ask GamerSupps to sponsor it.
Instead of going up to drink from the cup of wine, you drink from the...
GamerSupps cup of...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, that's wild.
A cup of GamerSupps.
You're so bad.
Black Panther, you're so bad.
I, like, instantly froze him.
I am the counter dive.
He's back.
Oh, he is back.
He had the res.
Oh, my God.
And then, like, you use the cup of waifu every time.
And then, like, what would be, like, the...
And then... Oh, no, you get baptized in the...
You get baptized in the GamerSupps.
It becomes, like...
It becomes...
Are you truly dedicated to the church of YouTubers if you don't get baptized in the pool of GamerSupps?
You get to pick your flavor, though, at least.
In the hot tub.
Yeah.
But, hey, you get to pick your flavor.
Isn't that the best part?
Wait, do you have a flavor?
No.
But, like, when you get baptized, you get to pick the flavor you want to be baptized in.
Where?
Where did he Grooted?
This Groot is so weird.
I'm not sure.
Like, I don't know where he Grooted.
Where?
Like, where is the Bucky going?
There's somebody behind, buddy.
Oh, it's Rocket.
It is?
Yeah, he was just stalling on point.
Oh, I might be dead.
Oh, no, I got hit by the tree!
I got hit by the tree!
What the?
No, their Bucky is pretty decent.
Yeah.
He, like, one or two-shot me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
Why did he...
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try it.
Oh, wait, dude, he did kill the tank.
Okay, I didn't realize there's Psylocke.
But, King ran off of it.
I was like, yeah, kill the tank.
Jesus, their Bucky is carrying.
Alright, I'm just...
Hey, Bucky.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
I saw there was, like, a hack where somebody was playing Rocket and they were doing clean damage.
Oh, yeah!
Yes!
That's crazy!
And how did they even do that?
That is the crazy hack.
Like, I'm like... I actually want to know where he got that.
That's such a crazy thing to do.
Hello, fucking Cloco.
How many odds?
They used everything.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
They wasted it.
Yeah, they used, like, four ults.
That was crazy.
I was not...
Okay, we're wasting four ults.
We're wasting four ults.
That's alright.
That's fine.
We still have Rocket.
We still have my ult and then we still have Moon Knight ult.
I'm just surprised that...
Because we definitely did not need to use some of these ults.
Yeah.
It's fine.
I survived.
He headshot me, but I lived.
Oh, it's fine.
There's a Black Panther on point.
Just focus on the Black Panther on point.
I guess.
Can I put a rez on the freaking...
Please.
Please, just shoot him.
If there's a rez here, I'm shooting the rez so that we...
I got the Rocket.
Please.
Sorry, I killed them.
Final score.
1-2-0.
Alright.
I was gonna say more kills on our DPS, but pretty much...
Oh my god.
Yeah, we have...
We have more kills than her.
We have a better KDA than her Iron Fist.
Oh my god.
We're about to overlap the Iron Fist's KDA.
Well, that's me.
I can play Luna on autopilot.
I actually...
You played her so much, yeah.
Yeah, when you play a character so much, you can legitimately just have a conversation while playing, because...
It's just autopilot for me.
That's how I feel with Cloak and Dagger, especially because you don't really have to aim.
Yeah, it's just brain off, just chillin' type deal.
I can play another game while I'm playing this game.
Just Cloak and Dagger?
Just have Bloons on the side?
Pretty much, yeah.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, we have our very first Luna player.
Oh my god.
Oh, I just thought about that you're pretty much boosting me.
No, because I played DPS.
I played DPS.
It's okay.
It's not boosting, because I'm bad at DPS.
I'm also bad at DPS when I'm streaming.
Legitimately, I don't focus a lot.
So in the end, I'm not boosting.
I'm actually throwing your games.
Yeah, I mean, you're like top 500 support player, but as a DPS, you're just like a diamond or something.
Yeah, exactly.
It's fine.
I'm legitimately just... Oh my god!
Oh my god, Nimi!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Hello, Nimi!
Hello!
We had a good stream.
I saw she was playing that... was it a horror game earlier?
I saw that.
Which one?
I don't know.
It was something about choosing if you want to be a human or not.
I didn't read the title.
I saw the thumbnail.
I was like, that's freaky.
Freaky?
That's freaky.
I'm so bad at horror games.
But no, no, no.
I really can't do VR horror games.
Those must be up.
Oh my god.
No, I remember I tried to play... What was that?
One of the scariest horror games?
The one that was like PT.
I don't know the name.
I don't remember the name either.
It's like... I forgot what it was called.
I swear to god, if I see another Black Panther, I swear to god, I'm going to go to Wakanda.
No, they don't have one.
Good.
I was going to go to Wakanda and something was going to happen in Wakanda.
I will find him.
Oh, Visage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Visage.
No, I cannot.
Oh, yeah.
Heaven Factory was kind of scary when I played it.
It was a really short one.
Yeah, I thought it was.
I heard like... But it was so short though.
How was it scary?
It's because... So it's like a cabin comes out on the conveyor belt and then sometimes it's haunted, but then sometimes it's not.
Yeah, so what were some of the haunted things?
There's like a portrait on the wall and you go through the cabin a bunch of times and nothing's weird with it.
But then in one instance, like the portrait turns and it's like following you.
And then in one instance, you see it, it's normal.
And then as you turn around instead of a portrait...
Because it's a portrait of a woman in like a really long dress.
And then she's just standing there staring at you instead of like in the portrait.
She's like... Her whole body appears.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't like that.
That's so freaky.
I'm so bad.
Like I once like... When I tried to play Visage, I legitimately... I got drunk.
Because I was like...
You thought it would help?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like liquid courage, you know?
I got drunk and then I didn't... Okay, my chat knows about this because I told this story before.
And then like... I didn't... Have you ever played Visage?
No, I don't think so.
Okay, so there's... The thing they didn't tell you is that...
The first part is a level select.
So it's not even like... You don't get in the game.
But I didn't know that because you're like walking around the house.
But you're supposed to pick up items to like... Start the game.
So I was stuck in there for like an hour plus.
Because I was just like... Oh my god, I'm so scared.
When does the monster come out?
When does the ghost come out?
And then I found out after an hour and a half.
My chat was like... You're in the level select.
You gotta pick up an item.
And I was like freaking the fuck out.
And then the moment I picked up the item, I just... I couldn't.
It was actually... It got bad.
It was so bad.
It's so... It was like... Oh, I lost track of where the fucking wall was.
That sounds confusing though.
I think I'd probably get it confused too.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Oh, I'm so dead.
I thought I had the snowflake still.
That's fine.
And then like, I couldn't... And then I picked up the level, technically.
And then after that, I like...
I couldn't do it, so I looked up a YouTube video of the first level.
I was like, let's watch.
Hey guys, let's pretend to play the game, guys.
But even then, I was so freaked... I was so scared even then.
Even when I was like pretending to...
Pretending to play it, I was still scared.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
I got three though.
I got three kills.
We win this easily.
Now I'm gonna play Starlord.
Nice.
I'm just gonna play Starlord and fly over.
Anyway, I'm supposed to... I'm actually supposed to play Visage like this year because it's a charity goal.
But like...
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I'm definitely gonna drink for it.
I can't.
I can't play it sober.
Hey, oh my god!
It's gonna be our second win in a row, Doobie!
We break the streak!
We're gonna do it!
I'm so proud of us.
All it took was just not focusing on the game.
Just playing mindlessly, yeah?
Yeah, just not even... We're not even focused on the game anymore.
I feel like if I played in a stack or something...
Well, maybe it's just a problem with players in the game, but...
Even when communicating, it takes a lot of brain power.
Yeah.
It does.
For Stylok, I legitimately... I'm not even thinking.
I'm just mindlessly shooting my hands.
I just go pew pew pew pew.
Do you usually like... I know in Overwatch, the supports usually show colors.
Yeah.
Is it the same for this game too?
It's the tanks.
It's not even the... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which is a lot different, because the tanks control the ults and stuff.
So they know when to do the ults and everything.
So usually the tanks are the IGLs for this game.
Which is a lot different.
I think it's like... I mean, the support helps out too.
But it's not like... They're not the main shot caller.
They do like... They mostly do like ults.
Ult tracking?
Ult tracking, yeah.
Man, thank you again for the raid, Nini!
I hope you had a great stream!
I heard Nini is like really good at like MOBAs.
Oh?
Yes.
Have you played MOBAs?
No, I'm so... I refuse to play League.
You should play Heroes of the Storm.
Oh, Heroes of... Wait, is that still alive?
Is that game still alive?
Wait, I'm so surprised.
I'm actually surprised Heroes of the Storm is still alive.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I don't like playing League of Legends, but I think Heroes of the Storm is really fun.
I've never played... I've never played League before.
I mean, I played it once like years ago.
Oh my god, you're so bad, Storm.
I clearly...
Okay, I might die doing this, but like...
Nope.
I'm fine.
Alright, kill two.
We should be able to move up now.
They don't have a support anymore.
I have Rocket.
Oh no, is that Rocket?
They had Rocket.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, I know how to play Sidelock again.
I figured it out.
You just had to warm up, yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
It just took me like a couple of hours, you know?
It took me a couple of hours to warm up.
What the fuck are you doing?
Whoa!
Alright.
I guess you're gonna do that.
Did they ult?
No, he was just like chilling.
But like...
Oh, hello, Sharkboy.
Hello!
What are you trying to do, Sharkboy?
That's fine.
I have ult here.
Alright, yeah, get in this point.
Oh, easy.
Oh my god, the hella god damn play.
She literally got to play a game in one second.
Really?
I tabbed, I was ace, and then I just saw my ace go away the moment we won.
Did she get it?
I guess she would've got it.
Yeah, like what did you do?
Oh, she had more damage, nevermind.
She had more damage.
Did you rank up?
Yeah, I just...
Yippee!
I'm the rank that we started with.
Wait, you ranked down?
Yeah, we lost like two games.
I didn't know, I thought you were flat.
No, no.
I de-ranked the gold too, and then...
Okay, alright, don't worry.
I just ranked back up.
We'll get you there.
You'll boost me?
No, no, no, we're gonna play well to get there.
Right, right, right, right.
It doesn't count, because you're not playing support.
You're right, because I'm boosting myself, because I win.
I'm boosting myself.
Oh my god.
Lord Hawkeye, that's crazy.
Don't worry, I've remembered how to play Psylocke now.
Hey, at least one of us is climbing, you know?
Wait, you mean you and not me?
It's better if at least not both of us are losing, you know?
One of us is climbing.
Wait, does that happen, like you're getting more points than me?
MVPs get more points.
Yeah, that's why DPS players climb so much, because it's so easy to get MVP.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah, but like, I've always wanted to try Heroes of the Storm.
We should do it.
Heroes of the Storm?
Yeah, we should play it.
I really like it.
We should do Mimi and then...
How many players are in Heroes of the Storm?
Five, I think.
Five?
Yeah.
I'm willing to do Heroes of the Storm because they're Starcraft characters and I love Starcraft.
Yeah, yeah.
And Overwatch characters.
Oh yeah, that's true!
There's Tracer too, right?
Yeah, but they kind of suck.
Yeah, yeah, you can teach us.
Except Lucio.
Lucio's really good in Heroes of the Storm.
Who are the best characters in Heroes of the Storm?
I'm just surprised there's still a player base.
Yeah, well, it's like a game that's been around for a while has like a dedicated player base, but then you find somebody that has...
They're like level 500 or something crazy.
Oh, true, true.
I don't know who the best are.
People always play this one character, Abathur, where he just sits in the back of the map and he has like a little parasite that sticks onto other players.
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, that sounds broken.
Yeah, and I thought for the longest time, I thought that like people who played him were just AFK because they just sit and spawn.
Where's my team?
I'm on point.
No, no, where's our Captain America?
No, look at our Captain America.
Wait, I think he DC'd.
Our Captain America DC'd!
Is he like...
No, look at him!
Oh, he's walking into the wall.
No, he's not even walking, he's just...
Oh, wait, is it one minute?
If it's one minute, the game cancelled.
Yay!
Oh, okay.
Yay, not punished!
Yeah, we kind of had a bad start anyway, so this works out.
Let's go!
I'm so happy, never punished, guys.
That's the best part.
Saved.
Yeah.
Oh my god, game queued longer than five seconds, the game's dead.
Oh yeah, I have... I wanted to show you something.
Oh yeah?
Oh, because I saw your tweet, I was like, there's two doobies.
Oh, there's two doobies?
I wanted to show receipts because I had this... I'll send this picture to you so you can verify.
Wait.
I remember when I saw you debut, I was like, what the hell are designs?
Because I'd never seen your design before.
So I was like, I was already in the process of designing Doobie, and so I was like, damn, it's kind of similar.
Blondes, blondes with green eyes, short hair.
And then the hat is similar too, and I'm like, shoot.
But then I saw you were getting a redesign, and I was like, oh, okay.
That was fun.
And then it looks even more similar.
Kind of, a little bit.
I even told my artist, I was like, I'm nervous, can we try not to get the hair...
Just change the color a little different, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
I told him, I was like, no, you know, be careful with the ahegao, the hair.
The little cowlick.
Yeah.
I had someone, I think it was my New Year's stream, someone in my chat came in during New Year's, I think he was drunk, and he was super chatting me and being like, oh my god, I'm so happy to have you here, Doobie.
And I was like, yeah, Doobie?
And he kept super chatting me, he was like, oh man, Doobie, this is what a great stream.
Yeah.
I had already picked the name out, so I was like, oh, this is kind of similar.
Doobie and Dookie.
Yeah.
D&D.
Oh, that's a good name.
Yeah, that's a good name.
I saw people asking, like, what's the collab name, Dookie?
And I'm like, I'm not gonna respond.
D&D is way better.
D &D is so good, yeah, I like D&D.
Oh, apparently I said the wrong word, it's, what is it?
It's not ahegao.
I don't want to say it too, because I know it's, I'm scared too.
Wait, what is the prop ahoge?
They sound really similar.
They do, they sound so similar, like...
Is he F'ed activated?
Yeah, no.
Especially for me, because I've, uh, I tried, there's like one time I tried saying Sega Genesis, but instead I said Aega Genesis.
And I was, like, working at a convention, so...
Yeah, yeah, and you're just like all, you know, the kids too, and you're like, oh, fuck.
Sega Genesis.
I'm, like, supposed to be kind of a spokesperson for this stuff, but I'm...
Hey, hey, you are!
You are, though!
You're very inclusive, you're...
You know?
What?
You're very inclusive.
Yeah, I'm including dyslexic people.
Alright, let's see, oh, come on, Cloak!
Come on!
Oh, yeah, you're gonna run away, little boy?
You're gonna run away?
Oh, you know what, fuck you guys.
I'm gonna kill you guys just for the sake of it.
We won the fight, but I just...
I'm giving them a message.
Whoa, I've never seen those Groot skins before.
Is this new?
Which one?
Like, blue crystals?
Uh, no, it's an old skin, it's just there's, like, better skins.
Not old, old, but, like, it's been a couple of weeks.
It looks, like, blue raspberry flavored.
Ooh, where are they?
Are they going main?
Oh, they are.
Come on, let me farm you up here.
That's right, give me free farms.
That's right.
Oh, they went Thor.
Yeah, but they're just pushing, like...
Yeah, like, they're...
Yeah, I was like, yay, I'll charge!
That's strange as all, but he's, like, not having a good time.
Oh, wait, they went... they did a cloak up.
But he's, like, not going... he did a cloak up and then he ran off his ult.
Yeah.
I was like, what are you doing, buddy?
Are you okay?
He's not okay.
Come on.
Lower elo is so difficult sometimes because they move, like, so predictable.
But I'm not used to predictable movement.
Yeah.
Used to playing against actual good players.
Like, I'm used to players doing, like, really fucking weird strafe patterns.
So when they move, like, in a way where I don't expect...
I'm like, you're not... don't move like that!
Don't move like that!
And my muscle memory fucks up.
Alright.
Hello, guys.
Hello.
Hello, goodbye.
You can't get healed in your ult, can you?
Uh, no.
I can't get damage in my ult.
So it's fine.
So, like, I don't worry.
That exchange has ult.
So careful.
He's literally looking for it right now.
Yeah, he is.
Yeah.
There he goes.
Nice.
He fucked it up.
He fucked it up, too.
Oh, nice.
We win.
Goodbye, judge!
Let's go!
Look at that.
We're so warmed up now, Doobie.
We're so warmed up.
Let's go!
The least obvious strange ult in the world.
He's like, let me just walk forward.
They'll never know.
Yeah, it's kind of like Reinhardt, how you can tell when they have their ultimate.
Yeah, yeah!
They just try to walk forward and just be like...
You're just like, I wonder what they're gonna do right now.
I do hate going against a good strange, though, where they just obliterate you.
Like, he does so much damage.
Oh my god, when he flies up in the air and does this fucking Agumado.
Yeah.
And then you just don't expect it.
Somebody in the chat noticed that the other team doesn't have any kills.
Oh my... and we have zero deaths.
We have zero deaths!
At least we know they're actual good players.
Thank god.
Thank god I'm fighting real golds.
I need this ELO, guys.
I need it so bad on my other alt account.
When the season resets, what do you get from your main account?
It was plat 1.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it wasn't that bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was really easy to...
Well, yeah, because all the other players are also plat 1, so it's not like, you know...
It's not like too bad for ranked games.
The games are actual high ELO games and stuff, so it was fun.
Yeah, because a lot of people get put...
I mean, yeah, especially at the start of the season, that's where they all get put.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna go flank.
I'm gonna do something crazy with my rocket jump.
That I learned.
Rocket jump?
Yeah, yeah, the rocket raccoon jump.
Let me see if I can dash up without using it.
Yeah, I can.
Wait, they're just here.
Goodbye.
I'm literally in their... behind them.
But they're like...
Nice.
They're like playing on like...
Why are they playing like this?
They're playing on point.
It's so weird!
Oh my god, they all want me dead.
Why are you playing like this?
I refuse to acknowledge this.
Why are you guys being such freaks?
I'm just gonna play frontline.
They have too much like...
They have way too much damage in the...
Protection in the back.
I guess they were ready for you, probably.
I know.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
We need that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't die now.
Oh, I got fucking pulled into it!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Nice, Brutal.
Wait, we win.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, let me just ult this too.
Don't!
The group wall!
I like...
I ulted the wall.
Oh.
I jumped at the point.
It was our own wall too!
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, I wanted to ask you.
Are you a bird?
Yes, I'm...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a bird.
So I'm like...
What type of bird?
Like a doki bird.
I am one of my species.
You're only one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm literally like...
Like endangered species, guys.
So I'm accepting donations to...
Save the species today.
Save the doki bird.
Save the...
Wait, what kind of...
What kind of germ?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're like a...
Oh my god, what kind of...
The specific rat.
Like a...
Wait, gerbil?
Gerbil, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, it's not a gerbil.
You said gerbil, so I was like...
Oh yeah, gerbil.
That's what I thought you were gonna say.
No, no, you said gerbil.
I was like...
Yeah, gerbil.
No, it's like...
It's like those jumping rats.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's what...
Short-eared gerboa.
Yeah, yeah, gerboa.
Little jumping rats.
Oh, I'm liking a little bit, so my...
I might look pixelated somewhat.
I can't believe it, you baited me.
You said...
Yeah, it was a test.
It was a test.
Oh my god.
Freaking failed.
My chat was like, she's germa.
You're a germa rat.
The first three letters are correct.
Yeah, it was like...
It's a past, you know?
It's technically a past if you think about it.
It's not my fault my professor baited me.
Gerbil is spelled with a G.
That's true.
Oh wait, is gerboa spelled with a J?
Gerboa.
What's the lifespan of a gerboa?
It's like 10 years in captivity.
Oh shit, are you in the wild or are you a captive gerboa?
Despite all my rage, I'm just a rat in a cage.
You're just a rat.
What was it called?
Wagee?
A wagee cage.
Stuck in the cage-y.
Wait, technically you are, because you're forced into the train cage.
Yeah, yeah.
Wagee cage-y, guys.
Free her.
Someone free her from the trains.
It's kind of like a purgatory thing.
Yeah, wait, that's worse.
Give it to the group.
Not the wagee cage.
Wait, how do you get paid?
What does the conductor pay you in?
Coins.
Coins?
But like, you're in purgatory.
How do you buy anything?
I mean, there's some towns, you know.
There's some towns.
Universal currency.
Yeah.
They should pay you in gold.
Gold never lose value.
Those people who just put their entire savings in gold and then bury it outside.
I don't understand why gold is so valuable anyways.
You can't use it for- it just looks nice.
It's just like- it's like- because you're like, oh, gold is like the universal currency type deal where like, it's a fixed price type.
But like, that's not true.
Because gold can fall in value, but some people are like, oh no, it's gonna go back- it's like socks.
You know, like, gold will come back.
The value of gold- That's what I heard.
It's probably different where you are, but the banks here are like, insured, I guess.
The FDIC government insured up to a certain amount.
I guess people are talking about that they're gonna take it away soon, so everybody's talking about buying gold.
Just to make sure.
That's like actual conspiracy theories.
I just realized we only have Root as our king, and our Groot was like, not feeling okay.
Our Groot.
I got you.
I'll go first.
Woo, I'm dancing.
Come on.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Calm down, sir.
That's- Oh, whoa.
It's okay.
I got frozen.
Oh my god, I got solo ulted!
He's so- that freak.
He actually solo ulted me.
I feel like maybe it'd be good to- What is it, like copper wires, people?
Copper wire?
Yeah, because they'll be used for electronics and stuff, so maybe it'd be good to stock up on that.
Make their own 50-80.
If the social economy or whatever collapses, then you can make your own graphics card if you have the right tools.
Our Wolverine just- Our Wolverine killed himself, but then the Iron Man just flew away.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Oh my god, it's fine, we're okay.
Oh my god, I'm gonna play in your ult.
That's right.
I'm gonna kill this Iron Man, because he's too- This Iron Man is too stupid to go in her luna ult.
Oh, wait, that's our only tank though.
Oh, wait, he did!
Oh, no, no, no!
I'm watching Gru walk backwards!
No!
Then he'll be back.
Then he'll be back, right?
He's not lonewolf69.
Lonewolf69, come back!
No!
Oh, he's back, he's back.
Oh, he is lagging, he is lagging, lagging.
I'm teleporting right now through the walls.
Can you heal me real quick?
Where is he?
I'm here, I'm right beside you.
He's walking over as best as he could.
He's very slowly walking over.
He's trying his best.
Our Moon Knight is our tank right now.
Nice, good job.
And the worst part is just the fact that I had to look at our Gru just standing still.
Standing still while we all got Strange ulted, that was so sad.
That was actually so sad!
We probably could have held the point if he did it this way.
100%, I agree.
Alright, I'm grabbing the Strange.
C'mon, c'mon Strange, go die!
Wait, are you like scared over these guys?
Oh, maybe I'm scared too.
She's getting healed and I'm not.
She has like a Rocket Heal with her.
Is Rocket Heal really that good?
I always thought he was kind of like a...
It's alright, but I was 1v2ing a Rocket and Luna and I was like, oh yeah, you win this.
My shift doesn't outheal that.
Oh my god, we definitely could have full health.
That is the furthest...
That kills him!
No, you died!
I was like, that is so far, that's no way.
There's no way!
I thought I'd live this!
I thought I'd live!
It's okay, I just wanted to give him like a satisfaction.
You know, I died on purpose to make him feel good about himself.
Yeah, then he'll psych himself out.
He's gonna be overconfident.
Yeah, exactly.
He's gonna be playing so overconfident because he thinks he's him, you know?
He's like, I'm him right now.
I'm that guy.
Oh, we actually have a second tank?
Oh my god, in gold?
Finally.
Oh my god, who are you?
Oh my god, you don't deserve to be in this healer if you're willing to swap.
What were they playing?
I don't need a DPS that was not doing anything, I think.
Was that our Wolverine, I think?
Yeah, it was our Wolverine.
He has four kills.
He has four kills, it's 100% our Wolverine.
Do people play Wolverine at like a higher rank?
Oh my god, they do.
It's so scary.
If you're playing Wolverine at a low ELO, then you're a bad Wolverine.
A good Wolverine is very, very scary.
He can basically 1v6 everybody.
How is he so tanky?
His passive.
He can't die right away.
But his passive, he basically can grab some...
Also, if you're playing with a good team, a magneetle will shield him when he goes in.
And then you put a snowflake on him and he just never dies.
And then he just grabs a tank.
He kidnaps tanks and stuff.
Does he have lifesteal?
Because I always see him gain shield.
No, that's his passive.
So if he's about to die, he gains shield type deal.
And he has damage reduction.
Kind of like Venom's shield.
But Venom's shield, you pop it yourself.
For Wolverine, it happens automatically.
That's why in higher ELO, everybody just bans Wolverine.
Because nobody wants to play against a Wolverine.
Is it just this, Ethan?
Because he got a buff?
Yeah, he got a buff when he's already so strong.
The only tank you can play against a good Wolverine is Magneetle.
Because he can shield everybody.
A good Wolverine is actual game changer.
Every single Wolverine I've seen in this ELO.
I like that one where they go off the side of the map.
Oh yeah, the Wolverine memes.
Have you seen the Wolverine memes?
I don't think so.
Wait, you haven't seen the animal?
Oh my god, you haven't seen the animal?
Okay, I'll send you the video.
It's so good.
It's my favorite.
I always think about that.
That and the Roblox meme is like the two memes that's been living breath-free in my head.
Okay, goodbye Hulk.
He tried.
What are you doing?
He like jumped in and that froze him.
He popped me off real fast.
Thank you.
He just jumped in and was like, this is it.
This is my time.
He is definitely not a Hulk player, that's for sure.
I'm just trying him out.
Oh, they're healing each other.
Alright, that's fine.
The two supports ran away.
Oh, they're running triple support.
Their Hulk is lagging.
What is he doing?
His best.
Where did the Iron Man go?
The Iron Man disappeared.
Oh, pretty fast.
What?
He just killed his Hulk charger.
This guy does not play Hulk.
Oh my god.
Iron Man's above.
Oh, he is?
Where is he?
He's like behind.
I'll kill him.
I kill him or I die.
He's just standing really far away.
Okay, maybe I do die?
No, I kill him.
Let's go.
I got you.
Okay, it's fine.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Hulk charge.
Alright.
He has ult, right?
I'm pushing the point.
We're already going to cap it right now.
Our penny was just on the point.
Maybe the Hulk wanted to be on stream.
What is he doing?
No, I'm pretty sure because they have an Iron Man player and report the RTT.
Which one?
Yeah, which one?
Oh my god.
I'm going to say, which one?
They were all pretty bad.
I'm not going to lie.
I had no idea who we were talking about there.
I can't get it.
I didn't say it.
It was them.
They said it.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, they have a plat on the other team.
No, we have Delft Destroyer.
It's okay.
We got him.
He's going to clutch it for us.
I believe in him.
Alright, MrDuckTurtle, the bucky player.
Alright.
Sidelock time.
GoldenBelow is toxic and terrible.
Oh no, people in my chat, you think GoldenBelow is toxic and terrible?
Hielo is just as bad.
I feel like it's higher stakes and people get even more angry maybe.
It's because people in Hielo have bigger egos too because they think they're the very best type deal.
But then the funny thing is that if they lose a game that they think they're going to win, their mental is destroyed for the rest of the day.
If you win against them one time, you fuck their mentals because you think they're the very best and then they're like, wait, am I not the very best?
That's the best part.
They actually break, yeah.
They start breaking and start picking troll characters because they think it's over.
There's a secret hole.
Oh, there it is.
Secret tunnel.
Are they TPing?
Okay, I used my invis too early there.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
Everybody's dead.
Okay.
Oh,
we might have lost the point, but I fucked over the Punisher.
I made a statement.
Alright, we'll go up.
That Punisher did not turn around.
It was funny.
How does the enemy team already have so many kills?
I don't know.
I left you guys for a second and then a lot of stuff happened.
It was crazy.
I'm just gonna farm this guy.
Bro, he's just getting- Oh, wait.
Nevermind, he's not getting healed anymore.
Bro, he was an ult battery for me.
It was crazy.
Like, I'm not complaining.
I am a little low though.
Alright, I'm gonna grab this real fast for us.
Oh, that's bad.
I can't do anything aside from here.
There's always too much healing going on.
Oh, wait.
Nevermind.
He's fucked up his grapple, I guess.
Oh, we're portaling.
Oh, we are?
Yeah.
There.
Oh, that's- Whoa.
Are you guys okay?
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
I'm getting a little bliss, I guess.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, where am I?
Where am I?
I'm healing.
I'm being kicked up everywhere.
Alright, I'd swap.
I can play Trihella.
Maybe.
What was the portal like?
It was like- It was something.
Trihella, if it doesn't work.
I wish I could play Wolverine.
I could fuck up this route if I could.
Oh my god, I die- I get melted so fast.
No!
Alright.
I guess the easiest would be Punisher and just use the Groot as an ult charge battery.
Wait, we have a Groot?
Oh, they have a Groot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was like, but Punisher is- like, Wolverine is easy- No, it's not.
It's not.
He's actually pretty difficult to learn.
Or do Bucky.
Bucky might be good.
Do you think we could play TripleSport and then go rocket him?
Ooh, yeah, we could.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying because it wasn't working last round.
Yeah, let's try this.
Should I switch to dive?
At the moment, we just need more damage on the Groot and it should be fine.
Yeah, if you were like- Guys, you guys don't understand.
It's so hard to grab people as Wolverine.
I always grab nothing.
It does seem- I don't know.
Like a high-skill feeling, right?
Yeah, yeah, super high-skill.
There's just so many buttons and everything.
Oh, doesn't he have combos?
Yeah, yeah, he does.
It's so hard.
Mostly, I just- I would ult nothing too.
I always get confused on how to ult with him.
Because I just be like, how?
How the fuck?
Did you watch the new Deadpool movie with Wolverine?
Oh, yeah.
I liked it.
It was like a- Like a yaoi.
Yeah, the car scene.
Oh, shit.
Oh, a team gave me ammo?
Oh, never mind.
Oh, shit.
It's so fast.
I don't know if they can focus me down.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, wait a minute, where did you go?
Oh, what the fuck?
I thought he was gonna die for that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yay, I'm back!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Okay, whatever you want.
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my- No, what the fuck?
I can't even like, peek.
That's crazy.
It won't even let me peek.
Oh, that's it.
I'm gonna ult- I'm gonna do it again and then I'm gonna play Punisher because I know I'm gonna die.
Alright.
I literally just sat there for like one second and died.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Hey, we gotta kill Elise.
I'm gonna be- Am I dead to this?
Okay.
No, but I'll be dead to this.
Oh, okay, he clicked it.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I wanted to swap to Punisher.
I feel like I just needed to like- I was like, who do I kill?
Maybe I should shoot at the one character that can, you know, dodge it.
That's so smart.
And this is like my third time playing Bucky, I have a confession.
That's okay, it's good practice.
Oh no, no, no, I'm dead.
It's practice, exactly.
It's good practice, exactly.
I literally come back just to die because everybody's- Yeah, you got ulted.
I come back and I have to die.
I'm so sad.
No, our moves ready.
Reset, everybody, reset.
Just reset, guys.
I'm just going to put your ammo down.
Okay.
Whatever.
I haven't been able to use it at all.
Oh my god, he's just ult charging for me, but like, he doesn't care.
That's the messed up part, he doesn't care.
Jesus Christ, like, what do I do?
I can't, I can't live.
I can't live.
Oh my gosh.
Also, I need to make sure to take off my tog.
Every time I play Punisher, I keep forgetting.
Alright.
It's okay, it's not us.
It's never us.
No, we've been winning, so it's not us.
It's not us, it's never us.
Good night.
Look, it's always... It's everybody but us.
Yeah.
I mean, it's definitely not you.
Since you're carrying me, it's definitely not me.
Yeah, yeah, and it's not you, so it's everybody else.
Like, you know, it's so difficult to, like, deal with four other crutches, you know?
Four other players with no hands, you know?
And they had a plat player!
Like, what are we supposed to do?
They had a plat.
Yeah.
Oh, this one also... Oh, wait, we have a plat too, so it's fine.
Yeah, now it's fine.
Now that we have a plat player, things would be easier now.
Do you listen to the in-game music, or do you have, like, a proper in-game music?
Yeah, I do.
Because, like, I don't mind... I don't like playing with, like, random music while I'm playing.
Because I like to focus up and stuff, so...
It can be distracting.
Yeah, and I listen to this music so much that it's just, like, easy to tune out now.
Alright, back to Psylocke.
Psylocke's so fun to play.
Have you ever played Psylocke?
No, I've never played her.
It's like Genji, right?
Yeah, it's like Genji, but, like, easy Genji.
Because her shots are, like, hitscan.
Oh, and also the ult is, like, automatic, right?
Yeah, yeah, like, you don't have to worry, just...
But there is RNG to her ult, though.
Because, like, you don't know where it's going to focus and type E.
Oh, shit, I never tried the portal?
Oh my god, that's cool.
I don't know the matchup.
Wait, what does she team up with?
She teams up with Black Panther and Magic.
So, like, I can use her Magic portals.
Oh, that's cool.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
We got this, I believe.
We're climbing.
We're technically positive right now.
Right?
For what?
Are we up, right?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what was your number for the gold one?
What number were you at?
Um, what do you mean?
Like, the points?
Oh, yeah, yeah, the points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we were at, like, 80 and then we lost points right now, so I think it's like 60.
Okay, so, we're close.
Yeah.
Oh my god, they're so low.
I'm lagging.
No, no!
It's okay, you're alive!
You're alive!
If you're lagging, you're alive!
You're so healthy!
I'm literally seeing you're very much alive!
I'm getting, I'm getting the lags, guys.
You're so healthy right now.
I'm not looking, but I'm pretty sure you are.
You're like a doctor, like, oh, the baby's so healthy!
Yeah, yeah, the baby is so healthy right now!
Oh my god, wait, they're doing triple support.
What the fuck?
Do not panic, you're so healthy!
Wait, what if I just...
What the fuck is going on in this fight?
What is this RNG?
No!
I got bad RNG.
What the fuck?
Stranger, are you okay?
Yeah, he's up here all by himself.
Oh shit, I've got to run.
I've got to run.
I don't want to be part of this.
I don't think he got anybody in there, did he?
Oh, his teammate.
Wait, wait, what?
He, like, taxied his teammate.
What?
What the fuck?
That's actually kind of smart.
Like, what if it's overtime instead of a strange portal?
It's like just ult and brings them to point.
Yeah, I could see that.
I've never seen that play though.
It was definitely very unique.
It worked, I think.
Yeah, it did.
It did work.
Because we weren't expecting it.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm going to wait until... Oh, we're still fighting?
Okay.
Bye bye!
Aww, whore.
He ulted my attack.
Oh, nice.
I do the same thing in games, but I say, like, uh...
I don't know, maybe I even say it on stream, you'll get demonetized.
Don't worry, I just said it.
It's a popular Australian word.
Just be an Australian and you get the pass.
Yeah.
No, it's not that bad.
It's alright.
She's like 1% Australian.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I just did that.
What was it called?
23andMe?
I don't even know if you did it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just to see if you're Australian.
No, I'm not.
I'm like 4% Chinese.
Oh, that's interesting.
What?
I didn't know that.
I was like, where did that come from?
I don't know.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Jin, this is insane.
This is like... I don't wonder why they have three supports.
The fucking backline does not exist.
Yeah.
They're having a rough time.
I believe.
I gotta be like, they're basically sisters!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Creep, creep, creep.
The only time I've ever used that before is like, I met up with someone.
Yeah.
It was like a...
Not in CS?
I was looking for a job.
No.
I was looking for a job, and I was like, I went to an interview type of thing, and it was kind of like a weird VR chat job where...
Yeah.
It was like before VTubers were popular, so they were trying to do like a VTuber thing, but in VR chat.
But they were trying to like, it's like a companion, like kind of like an adult thing, and I was like, oh, I don't want to do that part.
Oh, that's weird.
I don't want to do that part, but I can help you with like the 3D stuff, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, you can assist.
And they were like, are you Korean?
And I'm like, what the hell?
I'm not Korean.
Do I look Korean?
Maybe, I don't know.
About 4% Chinese, maybe that's it.
Maybe, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, we won.
Nice.
They just took it.
Just let us take it.
Wait, what's this group doing?
What are you doing?
You literally just walked up to me.
I'm like, yeah, don't mind if I take that extra ult charge.
Did they take that?
They're like, oh my god, you're hired.
Nah.
No, when I realized what it was, because I wasn't really sure what exactly it was before I went.
And so when I learned what it was, I was like, oh.
Okay, you're just like, no, never mind, I know how to do it.
I'm like, okay, yeah, we'll be in contact, sure.
Did they actually do anything about it in the end, or did the project just die?
No, I think the project just died.
And also, I looked it up afterwards, and it's against VRChat's terms of services to do something like that.
Oh, so it wasn't even affiliated with VRChat, it was just like a separate thing.
Yeah, no, no, no, no, no.
It was just somebody like, oh, I'm going to use VRChat to sell...
Yeah, yes.
You can't do that.
You can do it secretly.
And I think the concept too, they only wanted one character, but then they wanted multiple people to play the same character, if that makes sense.
Yeah.
I don't think people would like that anyway.
Yeah, that's like, people don't like that, because they'll be like, wait, but you said you liked this, and now you don't?
Catfish.
Yeah, I'm going to kill you, Mantis Story.
Alright, that's fine, that's a good exchange.
I used my ult just to kill that Mantis ult, so she used it for no reason.
Which is good enough for me.
Oh my god, I'm heading back, don't worry team!
The Psylocke is coming!
No, we lost our magic!
We lost the rocket.
No!
Oh, and we lost...
Yeah, we're down three.
I didn't realize that we didn't even have our special TP now.
Really?
Really, you died to...
Kill her!
Who's healing her?
Who's healing the Cloak?
I was shooting the Cloak for like 20 years, and I was like, who the fuck is healing her right now?
Oh my god, chill, chill, chill, chill.
That is ours, that's good, I'll play in it then.
Oh my god, that is... I'm just gonna farm ult.
Oh my god, I'm looking at the floor to make sure I don't die.
Oh no!
I got pulled.
Alright, I forced Mantis ult again.
Oh my god, I didn't have dash.
I forced the support ult.
It's fine.
We're still fighting?
Oh shit, okay.
Hey, we got to 99.
We got it, yeah.
Alright, it's fine, we got to 99.
That's all that matters.
I was like, what the fuck, why is...
Why is nobody... Oh no.
He's so low.
No, stupid triple support.
Stupid triple support.
Oh nice.
Aren't you like a pro, Mantis?
I killed her.
No, the storm!
I didn't expect to see the storm.
Somebody gets res'ed, I think.
No, I think Rocket res'ed somebody else, I'm pretty sure.
No, I don't think I should be the one swapping.
I think there is someone that's clearly underperforming.
Someone is clearly underperforming on our team.
It's not me.
No, it's not.
It is...
It's someone that's been... Oh nice, nice.
Oh, nevermind.
My field.
I see what you're saying.
He is not doing so well right now.
Hello, Sleugy.
He should play Magic.
Maybe they play support also.
Maybe.
Can you continue to play Magic?
I want the team up.
The team up is really good.
You only get it if it's all three?
Yeah.
Or... Oh, nevermind.
Thor is good too.
I mean, I can play Storm.
Fuck it, I'll play Storm.
I'm not good.
Storm has a team up, yeah.
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm better than the enemy Storm.
Psylocke is really bad with triple support, I feel like.
I don't know.
I just feel like nothing dies.
It's so difficult when nothing dies.
Yeah.
I've been against a few like...
That's why I don't...
That's why I don't like playing as triple support.
Just because nothing dies and it just feels so boring.
You're just rotating ults over and over again until something happens.
Oh, okay.
Alright, okay.
Do you think they'll change it and like next season or something?
I don't know.
I feel like... I mean, I hope they do.
But I feel like... Oh, another thing I don't know about playing Storm is just healing-wise.
It's like super risky.
It's easier for Cloak and Dagger to heal Storm.
Yeah.
Oh, I got my ult though.
Yeah, yeah.
We have like Rocket and they have triple support.
So it's easier for their Storm to live.
So it's hard for me to 1v1.
Oh, okay.
I'll do my ult and then swap because their...
Their support backline is better versus for heals.
Wait, are we still fighting this?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I died though.
Okay, I'm gonna stay here.
I don't think we need to fight this.
No!
What did the Cloak come from?
Okay.
Just sad.
Alright, I'll use it on...
I'll get... Yeah, I was like, I'm gonna get rid of this.
Goodbye!
What if they locked supports to only two per team?
Two per team?
Ooh, I would like that actually.
What goes well against triple support?
I guess I just play Hela.
Oh, nice!
I'll just play Hela just because we have a Thor.
And then we'll have the other team up.
I didn't think the Mantis would fucking run at me.
I ran up at the Mantis.
I was like, hello?
What are you doing here?
Don't you play her a lot?
Is that not how you play her?
Yeah, but she's trying to solo without her team so it was very weird.
You can technically burn it, but I don't even know if you have to.
Oh shit.
There we go.
I killed the Mantis, but...
No!
I was on point.
You could actually live on point with your ult.
But like, it's alright.
Your ult is so strong, you can actually live on point.
Oh yeah, but I lagged out and I teleported somewhere else where I had no idea.
It worked out though, I got out.
You're alive, you're alive.
Why do we still have rocket?
Maybe I should have just ran Punisher because we have a rocket.
Yeah, he's playing with the buggy.
Well, we just got one.
Okay, nice.
I might need heals, but...
Thank you.
She's still here?
Oh, she is.
Okay, nice.
She wasted it, she wasted it.
She wasted that.
No, I couldn't fly!
I did not fly anymore!
No!
I was trying to fly!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
No, I'm not.
I'm actually not.
I'm not fine with that.
Okay, we still have a healer.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Did you fly out of it?
No, he like didn't.
I don't know what he was doing.
He was playing really weird.
Okay, I'll ult.
I'll wait for my ult before I use it.
As long as we're all here.
Alright, bye ult.
Bye ult!
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
I'm gonna need heals the moment I ult.
Goodbye, Sharky boy!
That's right.
Wait, what?
I know Rek.
Goodbye.
There we go.
That's right!
How dare you run triple support in gold!
How fucking dare you!
Gold is supposed to be a sanctuary!
How fucking dare they!
Is there like a specific meta for 3 support or is it just any 3 support?
It's any 3 support.
Well, most likely it's Luna, Cloak.
Luna, Cloak, and Invisible Woman.
Or Luna, Cloak, Mantis.
You have to have a Cloak and a Luna if you can.
Cause they're like the strongest.
And a Loki too.
So if you can't have Luna or Cloak, then you can substitute with Loki as well.
But like, it's just, someone's like 3 support is like 24 7 diamond.
Please save us.
I'm so sorry for the triple support players.
Is there no way to counter it really?
There is.
You can run triple DPS.
Triple DPS, one tank.
And then a triple DPS has to like, you have to run magic with triple DPS.
Cause the magic can never die, basically.
And can get ult charged so fast.
And they can just farm the frontline over and over and over again.
And like, you have to have a Mag because a Mag can insta-kill like a support ult.
Other than that, you just run a better triple support.
What if they added like a character that had anti-heal?
Kind of like Ana's...
Oh, that would help a lot, yeah.
Anti-heal too would be really good.
Let's see, what does Captain Smackaho want to play?
I guess I'll try playing Luna Snow.
Wait, you can play DPS.
You want to play DPS?
I'll play Luna for you.
Um, I'll just play second tank.
Would you rather play support or tank?
I'll play tank.
Cause the guys asked for Luna Snow.
Yeah, but who cares about what he wants, though?
That's true, yeah.
If he played Amour, it's a good team-up.
Who cares about Chinny Chin?
What do you want to play, Doobie?
What do you want to play?
I like tank, I like tank.
Alright, alright.
It's kind of like the Stockholm Syndrome with tanks.
Queuing, nobody wants to play, so...
I like it now, though.
I like it.
Yeah, I like it.
Yeah, I totally like it.
You old, held hostage.
Only if it's Penny Parker or Venom.
I love it.
I do play in some games where they're like, can we get a strange?
And I'm like, oh, sorry, I only play Penny Parker.
You can play tank.
Yeah, exactly.
You can play tank if you want a strange.
Alright.
You can't be making demands here.
I won't negotiate with Terius.
Alright, that's fine.
Where?
You're fucking fully healed.
What do you want?
Don't be demanding.
Because I will refuse to heal.
Alright, this should be your rank up game, right?
Yeah, I'm like 9 points away.
Oh, this is... Okay, I'll full try.
Don't worry.
I'll hit every fucking shot here.
Like, not... That's my first pass, though.
Not this shot, though.
But now, I'll hit every shot.
See, look at that.
Now that you're playing your main, I mean...
Yeah, now that I'm playing my main, I'm gonna hit everything.
Right here.
Nobody will die under my watch.
And if they die, then like...
I can't save, stupid.
Don't watch over them.
If they die, I intentionally wanted them to die.
Like, it was just a plan that I had.
Oh yeah, my ult, too.
That's crazy.
I got my ult so fast.
Wait, just push forward.
Push forward.
You won't die.
Trust me.
Just push forward.
Just keep pushing forward.
You won't die.
Trust me.
Just keep pushing forward.
See, look at that.
Just keep going.
Keep going.
You're so alive.
You'll never die.
Oh my god, I can see you lagging.
I see you.
It's because I'm playing on Wi-Fi.
Wait, Wi-Fi?
Yeah, because I have Ethernet on my stream PC, but I haven't set up a special setup with my second Internet.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I was like, what?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
But I'm like right next to the Wi-Fi thing.
Alright,
let's go.
Double support ult because I waited for our cloak to ult and it took forever.
I'm damage boosting it though, so something should happen technically.
I guess not, but that's okay.
Let's just use everything, you know?
Okay, Moon Knight!
Okay, he ulted the corner.
That was crazy.
We didn't get it?
We were so close.
No, we didn't.
It was literally, we used every fucking ult except for our Neymor's ult.
They have Thor ult too.
The guy didn't use his Thor ult.
They use all their support ults, so we're fine.
What the fuck are you trying to do putting an Ankh there?
Who are you trying to kill?
Ankh.
Okay.
Yeah, the Ankh.
I'm gonna try and kill this Moon Knight.
Oh shit!
Oh, nevermind!
I didn't realize the entire team was back there.
Are they in there?
Yeah, all of them are back there.
I was not expecting that.
I was like, wait a minute.
Oh no.
It's alright, I agree.
It's okay.
Keep that group up.
I'm just fine.
Who's he gonna try and kill?
Oh, her.
He's dead, I mean...
Yeah, like, I mean it's a good exchange because he's killed his support.
I'm just gonna... I'm just focusing on Cloak.
There you go, Cloak is dead.
People play Thor in higher ranks?
There's four one-tricks, yeah.
He's not back there.
I don't find him.
I like, I had to frontline for our group.
He was behind me.
I was, like, scared.
Groot, Groot, go up!
You're a big tree!
What are you scared of?
You're a giant fucking tree!
Oh damn, Hawkeye.
Now I have to actually play passive.
Now I have to be careful.
Wait, what?
Who's over there?
He was over there.
Oh, I can kill this Hawkeye, I think.
Nope, he's getting me.
Yeah, he's low.
Oh, he's... he is low, though.
He's still low.
Oh, I was reflexed.
Don't worry, we don't need our Moon Knight.
He was useless.
Is he doing it?
Yeah, he's doing stuff.
He has 20 kills.
Do not ult, Cloak!
Oh, oh, that's fine.
I dodged it.
That's fine.
I'm assuming you guys are over here.
Oh, you're so healthy, Syl!
Oh, you are not.
You're going to die.
Oh my god, when was these ults!
When were our Namor... wait, our Namor ults?
When?
When the fuck did our Namor ult?
Do you have any advice for getting out of Silver?
There's some people that are stuck there.
For Silver, literally just play Rocky Raccoon.
If you really, really want to get out of Silver, and you really, really want to climb, play Rocky Raccoon.
He's that good?
He's that easy to climb.
He's one of the easiest characters to climb with.
Okay.
He is crazy.
I don't have Freeze.
I didn't have Freeze with me.
It's because his movement is so... He's unkillable in a lower ELO.
He's unkillable in the lowest ELOs and stuff because his movement is really good.
So it's really easy to climb.
Just focus on dodging and everything.
But I hate Rocky Raccoon players that are KDA players.
Because they do play like that.
Because they don't help with other support.
They play for their own lives.
So it's like one of the most tilting things when there's a KDA player.
Because they're so used to playing KDA.
I'm just up here getting whipped!
He's trying to... He's like, fuck this one particular Moon Knight.
Your ult doesn't make you invincible!
Okay...
That'd be crazy if he had like Life Steal or something like that.
Every time he Moon Knight ults, he like fucking walks into them.
And I'm like, Moon Knight, chill!
Chill, buddy!
Oh, I might be dead to this.
No, actually, I'm fine.
Our Cloak is, though.
What?
Portal?
Why?
It's where I do not look into it.
I ulted, but you are not invincible!
You are not invincible, Groot!
They have Strangelove.
I don't know if I can freeze this in time.
Maybe I can web him.
Oh, the Pokedagger is super low.
Sorry!
I used my freeze.
Did our Groot die?
Oh, he did die.
Yeah, he was the first one to die.
I'm just gonna wait until...
Nice.
We have ult.
I used my freeze, so I fucked up.
Because he has Strangelove.
If he does it, maybe he won't use it in...
Oh, nevermind, he used it.
It's fine, I saved him.
I'm a fucking hero.
Did you freeze him?
Yeah, no, I froze him after the ult, so I'm a hero.
Oh god, I'm like teleporting and ulting at the same time.
And I feel so bad for the team.
I see, but you got people.
That's crazy.
Oh, I can't fucking jump there.
Don't leave the cart.
If you guys can live, we're like...
Oh nice, we killed him.
We killed the Disappear.
Alright.
There we go, we did it.
I feel like we'll do good on defense too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Groot and Penny are really good for defense.
Someone's like weaponized lag.
If you're lagging, that means they can't hit you.
It's all part of my plan.
Exactly.
You're like TPing around them.
I mean, it makes it's lore accurate.
Exactly.
That's true.
She's portal jumping.
She's playing with portals.
I believe in this full hold.
The Wi-Fi.
I don't know how you can play with Wi-Fi.
That's crazy.
I don't usually.
It's just Wi-Fi because it's on my second PC right now.
Yeah.
That's actually like very impressive.
I think I would actually freak out if I had to play on Wi-Fi.
I was playing on low graphics too, but that's not too bad, right?
Yeah, everybody plays on low graphics.
I play on low graphics too.
It's just a gamer thing.
People will be like, wow, you have such a tanky PC, but yet you play everything on low.
And you don't understand frames are much more important.
Especially because I saw in this one, the more frames you have, the faster you move or something.
Yeah, yeah.
I know, like the more stuff you can do and shit, like that's so broken.
It's pay to win.
Yeah, it's literally pay to win.
The rich only gets richer.
They get everything.
The rich gets everything.
Yeah, frozen.
Oh my god, are you stupid, Neymar?
I literally froze him in front of the...
Oh, I can't get to you.
No, no, no, no.
Sorry.
No, our Neymar ignored the fucking frozen stream.
And then he was like, what's hitting me in the back?
Our Neymar was pretty dumb.
Headphones off, AFK.
Yeah, no, he's dumb.
Literally, like, we all saw the portal.
It's fine.
I can... I don't know if we should touch, but we can technically touch.
I'll try and get to you.
Here you go.
Yeah, you can... I think you can touch it, right?
I... I...
Oh, never mind.
Nope.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
I'll keep you guys up.
It's fine, it's fine.
You guys are still... You guys are still alive.
You guys are still alive.
I'm keeping you all up.
You guys are still healthy.
I'm keeping you all...
Okay, not you though.
Not you though.
Oh, no.
Armed and dangerous.
No, so close.
The armed and dangerous.
I can't believe I played Duna for this Namor.
I guess he's just a Namor one trick, probably.
A bad Namor one trick, I'm supposed to say it.
He was a... What the?
No, I got pulled.
I'm feeding.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Here we go.
I'll make sure to kill you.
It's fine.
We stabilize this.
Because I kill too.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
I hope we have a cloak off for defensive later.
That's what I hope for.
Alright.
I can keep every... I think, but yeah, I can.
I'm saving my ship.
I'm saving my...
It's fine.
They fucked up.
They fucked up their ult.
Everybody lives!
Nice.
There we go!
Look at us go.
We all live.
Oh, yeah.
You know, we don't... It's just three ults, you know?
It's just three ults.
We don't need those ults.
It's okay.
We don't need them.
I can... Yeah, we don't need those ults.
Oh my god, I see you.
It's always so funny seeing you TP.
I think I... Yeah, I don't know what's going on with my internet.
It's really bad right now.
It's fine.
That means they're seeing it too.
If I see it, they see it.
Yeah.
Oh, they double support ulted.
That's good.
I think I'm gonna die.
Jesus Christ.
Not yet.
Oh, okay.
Yep.
Yeah.
No.
I almost got it.
No!
I was trying to sneakily try and get my ult.
Cause I can... I could've saw it there.
Oh, that sucks.
I legitimately could've got my ult there.
If I didn't get shot by two people.
Oh, no.
They have four minutes.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
I'll play more... I'm gonna play more smart now.
Knowing this.
Alright.
I'm gonna keep my cooldowns until I actually need it.
Use it.
Nice.
We can push up with that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's push up with that.
Push up.
Let's go.
We're fine.
Our team is fine.
You just push up.
You're gonna be fine.
Cause we killed three.
So, you don't have to worry.
There's support so he can't kill you.
I'm lagging.
It's okay.
Even if you're lagging, it's okay.
Oh, shit.
Nevermind.
I can't trust you.
I forgot about the lag part.
That was my bad.
That was actually... I was like, oh shit, you're lagging.
I forgot all about that.
It's okay.
Oh, drop down if you need heals because there's the cloak up.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
I almost forgot.
That was my bad.
I forgot about the most important part.
It's okay.
Just keep running.
He has change up.
Oh my god.
I got pushed back.
Holy shit.
Oh no.
I can't outheal all this.
There's too many.
You're dead.
It's okay.
That's where you were.
You were dead.
If you're curious where you were.
Are you serious?
I get solo ulted?
That fucking freak.
You're such a freak.
You're next.
Oh my god.
He's trying to stall.
Me too.
Get on point.
DPS.
Why can't you ult but not on point?
You could've stood in his ult, right?
Yeah.
He literally ulted and then he didn't even go into the ult.
I'm so tempted to be like, let me play DPS.
I can't.
You guys are hopeless.
I don't think he'll give up DPS anyway.
I think Cap the Moon Knight is good.
But Chinny Chin?
He needs to swap his career.
Chinny Chin was the problem.
Captain Smack was doing okay.
And also...
Our group feeds so hard.
I can't even out heal it too.
I feel like the first round I was feeding a little bit.
But this one I tried to play more safe.
But it's still...
I don't play Magneto.
You can play Magneto.
Oh, Chinny Chin.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll play DPS and then you can play support.
And then you can play...
There we go.
I'll play Psylocke.
Actually...
I'll play Psylocke, yeah.
Alright.
Locked in.
This might be a little difficult.
But lock in time.
Oh, actually...
Can they play when it's not lagging?
Wait, you're right.
I just remembered.
It's strange just trying to...
I had to...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Wait!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I got one.
I got two.
Nice.
Oh, my snowflake!
Where's my snowflake?
Oh, no!
It's okay.
I got three.
Keep the snowflake on me.
And then I can kill everything, I think.
I think I can.
It only heals when I'm healing, right?
Yeah, you can heal me with it and I get double the healing.
And then you can heal other people.
You heal other people and I get the heals, too.
So that's why they keep it...
Keep it on me.
So then I can... I'm behind you.
Look at me.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit!
That's so much damage!
I couldn't even outlive that.
You can snowflake somebody else for now.
Because I...
I was just front tanking it.
I'm dead.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
You're so healthy.
We're good.
Guys, just stay alive.
I believe.
I need somebody else to be alive on this.
No!
I can't!
That's unlucky.
I thought someone else was alive.
I was so close to hitting my ult.
That's so unlucky.
If I'm in my ult form, I can't do anything.
I didn't try to play.
Yeah, just keep the snowflake on me.
And I'll play more conservative.
Yeah.
And I'll try and just pick off the supports.
I can play way far in the back, right?
Yeah, you don't have to play close.
The moment you heal them, I get healed.
Okay.
Yeah, because my ult form makes it so that I don't...
I stop existing.
I just don't exist.
Pretty sure my friends who are watching me play Psylocke are like, oh my god.
Get off Psylocke.
What are you doing?
They're like, what the fuck are you doing?
What are you...
What the fuck is this game playing?
What is this game?
Oh my god, are you dumb?
I'm sorry.
I'm gold.
I'm just gold.
I mean, if you have a DPS only account...
I remember people in Overwatch would do that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
DPS is so stressful to play.
That's why I don't play DPS.
It's just way too stressful.
What the fuck is he doing?
I'm just waiting.
Whoa.
Let's see.
I'm gonna try and annoy the supports real fast.
Oh no.
I should've gone around.
I didn't think they were that close.
I'm contesting point.
Oh shit.
Oh.
I was contesting point.
But our teammates are not having a good time.
I mean...
I got a contestant.
Oh no.
What?
I got pulled.
But I think it's the lag.
I used my freeze on him before he pulled me.
But it didn't register.
Oh no.
Our Venom is going fucking crazy.
Venom!
He just ran into it.
Okay, I got Bucky.
But that's it.
That's all I can do.
I got a kill.
But I couldn't do anything else.
We were so close.
I think if I saw...
I think if ChinnyChin played Mag earlier...
I think we could've won that.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
That game...
We don't need to avoid people.
Because there are so many players in gold.
Yeah.
It's unlikely we would get anybody else.
I feel like we haven't bumped into people.
We haven't bumped into the same players.
At all.
It must be pretty common for a higher rank rank.
Yeah, because there are less people.
But...
I haven't seen...
The players...
The players we bumped into in here.
It's all new guys.
I believe...
This is a game where...
We are going to win two in a row.
I believe.
And then you are going to be plat.
Let's go!
There is no way.
Nothing bad will happen to us.
Well, I mean...
That's just asking for it.
Nothing bad is going to happen to us.
We are not going to go into...
A five game...
A five game loss streak or anything.
I would like Ironman.
Do we have Hulk?
Do we have a Hulk player?
Question mark.
No, okay.
If I pick Ironman...
And they don't play Hulk, then it's obvious...
They are not a Hulk player.
Yeah.
Like I said, it's really hard to find tank players.
Oh, there we go.
But they are playing Brute though.
Brute.
A good Hulk player is so scary.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Let's see if I can get away with Ironman.
I just want to play Ironman for the right click.
Because the right click...
The clips, right?
The Jarvis clips.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That and then the right click is really...
The right click is the only tracking.
In the game.
And there's not a lot of...
Yeah, there's not a lot of characters that are tracking.
Oh, fucking let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god!
Freeze ball.
Can I have Snowflake?
I'll just be like...
Oh my god, come on.
Yes!
It's perfect!
I am the most optimal Ironman.
I'm gonna die instantly.
I'm gonna die instantly after I got everything I ever wanted in life.
I can feel it.
Gamma time.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
How is he still alive?
Holy shit!
They're gonna have ult soon.
They're 100% gonna have...
Ult for...
Support.
There's no way.
I literally...
I healed a bunch of damage.
I farmed...
I farmed all...
Nice.
Like...
I literally got...
Ult from this one group.
It's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
How is he still alive?
Oh, portal.
Yep.
I have to play like...
Come on.
That's great.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
It's fine.
We're alive.
We have local ult too.
Yeah.
It's worth it.
I have ult too.
That Groot is literally just letting me farm...
on him.
It's actually crazy.
I did not expect me to get...
an ult that fast.
I was just like, alright.
It was the beam, right?
Yeah.
We just used the beam.
I'm lagging really fast.
Oh shit.
It's fine.
Don't worry.
We got you.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna spam my heals.
So...
I think he...
Oh my god.
Clip it!
Clip it Jarvis!
Alright.
1-3.
There we go.
Jarvis, clip that!
Wait, what?
Hello.
Hello Luna.
Goodbye Luna.
Let me farm you!
For the next round.
Okay, I'm gonna be nice.
I'm gonna be super...
nice to my Luna.
You know what it's like to be...
in that position.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just gonna be super nice to our Luna.
Can I please have the...
Thank you Luna.
She's not giving me snowflake.
Luna, please.
I did so much.
Did you not see the cool ults I did, Luna?
Luna, please.
I was freaking carrying Luna.
I'm gonna hump you.
Don't make me do it.
Chad's confused.
They're like, what?
Don't make me do this.
She's not giving me the snowflake.
I even said thank you.
I don't think she's giving it to anyone.
Oh my god.
I even said thank you.
They don't have portal.
So they'll just be slowly walking.
Somewhere.
There it is.
Oh, thank you.
Oh no.
The moment she gruted the support.
It's okay, I killed Groot though.
Our Luna should be ulting.
Our Luna is a little...
Maybe is a little special.
She should have ulted.
I don't understand.
If she ulted this, we could have...
Oh no, not the...
Oh nice.
I'll play on this then.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know why she...
Wait, our Luna ulted?
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, Luna.
That was weird.
Just regroup.
Or...
Our other player is not going to regroup.
But that's okay.
I'm fine.
I'm just farming ult again.
Wait, I have ult.
There we go.
Okay, I need heals though.
I'm like, oh wait, it's okay, I'm fine.
I killed two.
Yeah, we're down to healer right now.
Yeah, I killed two though.
It should be fine.
Alright, I got Scarlet.
Oh, no, not Scarlet.
I got Luna.
Oh, nevermind.
I guess I don't got anybody.
Oh, he wasted it.
Alright.
Woah, woah, woah.
I'm okay.
I'm so healthy still.
I'm so healthy.
I'm on 3 HP, but I got two before I died.
I got two before I died.
That's good enough.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Our Luna still died.
I'm dead.
No supports right now.
Well, that's bad.
That's bad actually for me.
That's actually bad for me.
They have it.
They got it.
Yeah, they did.
Luna gave me snowflake.
That's so true.
Did she even use it on anyone?
No.
I don't know.
I just needed a snowflake.
Because Ironman is really difficult to heal in general.
And that's why you always give your Ironman the snowflake.
So you don't have to worry about healing.
I'm trying not to do crazy movement and stuff.
Because I don't have a snowflake.
Because our Luna can't heal me.
Maybe they're doing something while playing.
Yeah, maybe.
Luna...
I would really like a snowflake.
But that's okay if you don't want...
That's okay if you don't want to...
Oh wait, they play...
Wait, can you play Luna?
Or are you too laggy?
Me?
Oh.
Maybe they're too laggy.
Swap to Cloak and I'll swap.
Oh, I think...
Oh, never mind.
You didn't play Cloak.
We're not playing Hulk anymore.
That's alright.
I think they're...
I think they're duo'd with the Hulk.
And they were giving snowflake to the Hulk.
Which is a little crazy.
Which is dumb.
Because you can literally farm.
Okay.
Hawkeye.
There he is.
Yeah, their Hawkeye wasn't really doing that much last round.
He didn't really die either.
They were keeping him up.
That's fine.
I wonder if they'll ever change that.
Because she's so easy to kill.
Yeah, she is.
Oh, they're portaling.
That should be easy.
Oh, I was going to be like...
That should be predictable, right?
I didn't even hear it.
Oh, the portal was like...
Oh, they double support ulted.
Oh, okay.
That sucks.
I should've...
I mean, they used both support ults.
That's fine.
That's a good trade.
I didn't think they were going to use two support ults.
Oh my god.
I triggered the cloak ult, so...
She didn't have to.
I still have...
I can follow the scarlet.
Oh, she's going to use her second.
Oh, alright.
They're not healed.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Ult on the point.
Oh, it's on the...
Okay.
I couldn't see it.
There's so many colors.
There's so many things.
I was like, wait, where is it?
I'm going to farm you.
Bro.
I need ult.
It's fine.
Alright, this is okay.
This is okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And they're not going to fuck up the strange ult, too.
There you go.
I don't know why you egoed me.
Heal me real quick.
Thank you.
Okay, I got ult from him.
I'm going to have Luna ult, though.
What?
Wait, where?
Oh, I didn't see Hawkeye.
He's literally behind us.
Yeah, I didn't see him.
Excuse me?
I was like, wait a minute.
What?
What's going on?
Okay, no, no, no.
Come on, no, no, no.
Don't leave the point.
Strange, why you leave the point, Strange?
Now you're dead!
Okay.
Alright, I'll chill here then.
I have a little hidey hole right here.
Oh my god.
Bro, this guy really wants to ego.
Holy shit.
He's low.
I got it.
Okay.
We pushed in with that.
What?
Okay, I triggered the cloak ult.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for ults to be over.
Okay.
Oh no.
Wait, what?
Did he follow me?
What's wrong with you?
Hey, I'm going to solo ult you.
Oh no.
Oh.
That's fine.
I'm dead though, but it's fine.
I got three people on me.
We got three ults.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's a huge ult.
That's a huge ult.
Oh, we got the point too.
Wait, there's only two of you?
What happened?
Wait, just play on your ult.
I'm coming back.
Play on your ult.
Just go on point.
You can't die in it yet.
And I'm coming over too.
Oh, they ulted.
Yeah, but that's our ult.
I can kill the Luna.
I know I can kill Luna through it.
See?
Right here.
I'm backing up.
That's fine.
See?
Look at that.
We did it!
Yeah, that's why I said play on your ult because I know you can't die on your ult.
And then, Moon Knight ult, even the Luna ult, the Moon Knight ult can kill Luna if I shoot the Luna at the same time.
Nice.
Yay, we did it!
We did it!
That was too close, but we did it!
Yeah, that was close.
Oh, nice!
Nice.
Are you plat now?
I don't know.
No.
I need one more unit.
Are you plat?
Yeah.
Yeah!
We did it!
Doobie's plat now!
My ult account is plat.
My regular account is already plat.
Now your main and regular account is plat now.
Yippee!
That was fun.
Oh my god.
That was really fun.
I know like...
Oh my god.
Chat, if you guys didn't know, Doobie, we went to play together a while back, but then I got incredibly Marvel Rivals killed.
You had your own arc.
Yeah, I went into a rake.
We were supposed to play I think the first week or something and then I just got fucking Marvel Rivals killed into a rake and I didn't come out.
You fell into the pit.
I fell into the pit and Doobie was outside the hole looking down at me.
Yeah, pretty much.
Well, I know it's also your thing to play competitively, like super competitively.
But for me, I was just like playing for fun, like playing every now and then.
I was like, oh god damn, she's all the way up there.
I remember I messaged you and I'm like, oh yeah, I'm like gold one now.
Yay, if you want to play, just hit me up.
Yeah, and then I was like, oh, I'm GM.
A week later, like, hey, actually, I'm one of them all now.
No, it is really cool though, especially because you get to do so many tournaments and stuff.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's the fun part, but there's a lot of content creator tournaments.
Have you ever been interested in doing tournaments?
Just more so like casual.
Not really.
I mean, I just play with friends pretty much.
Yeah, tournament-wise, it's like a lot stressful too.
Like, there's so much.
It's not like, you know, one mistake can cost it and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I can understand.
It's fun to practice and scrim.
Scrims are fun.
Come up with comps and stuff.
Yeah, I think like scrim-wise, it's like really fun, especially like, I think the tournament itself is super stressful, but when you're scrimming and everything is super organized and you don't have randoms you want to fucking kick, like...
Did you participate in the last official tournament?
No.
Oh yeah, you were busy.
Yeah, I was really busy then.
And I heard it's like...
It was like... I think it was like 10 games, right?
Like 10 games.
Yeah, for the first qualifier, it was 10 games.
Yeah, and it's like spanning between like 2-3 months and stuff like that.
Oh, yeah.
The first one wasn't like... Maybe it was actually.
I didn't get that far, so...
No, like my friends who are pros and Marble Rivals, like, they basically... Oh my God, like they're like, oh, you could totally be pro if you actually commit.
I was like, no.
This is their schedule.
They like wake up, because I'm PST, so they wake up and then 11am they have to do VOD review for an hour.
And this is every day, by the way, guys, this is every day for Marble Rivals.
They wake up at 11am, VOD review, 12pm to 2pm, first block of scrims, and then one hour VOD review after, and then...
three to six, another scrim block, and then VOD review, and then rank.
And they do this every day, and Sunday is their only rest day throughout all of that.
How can they do this?
It's just passion.
Most people have jobs and stuff.
They're like paid to be a pro player, but even then, I don't think they're paid enough to do all of that.
They're like, why don't you try?
And I was like, because I make more money doing this.
I can literally just talk about random shit, and there's more money per hour.
And I was just like, Sunday's your only rest day?
And they're like, yep, Sunday's my only rest day.
I'm like, holy fuck.
Yeah, I feel like you get burned out so easily in the game.
That's why some of them don't even play rank, because it's just like, you know, rank right after scrims and stuff like that.
It's more stressful.
I know in Apex pro scene, there's some teams where it's mandatory for them to play at least four plus hours of rank after practices, too.
I know!
I was like, what?
That sounds crazy!
No, I wouldn't be able to do that.
Yeah, I was like, bro, I want to fucking, after stream, I just want to relax.
You could stream it as content, but then also if you do the same thing too much, people get tired of it.
Especially the same game, you stream the same game over and over again.
I don't know how people could do that every day.
That's why sometimes I like variety, so I can chill with that too.
You do a lot of unique stuff for your streams too, with your 3D and stuff.
I feel like you could play around so much with 3D.
Sometimes.
I haven't the past month because I messed up my studio a little bit.
Wait, what happened?
It's because preparing for the concert and stuff, I moved some things around to make it easier to do dancing.
I just haven't moved it back into place, so it's not ready for streaming type of content right now, but I'm gonna do it.
We'll do it, guys.
Tomorrow.
We'll totally do it.
We VTubers do not procrastinate.
I had so many cardboard boxes I had to get rid of, so I went to do recycling.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that's like...
I remember seeing your dancing and said the worm was crazy.
I told you, I told you.
I was gonna do it.
She did it.
She did the worm.
It felt like you guys hyped me up, though.
It was like the epic jump and I was like, yeah.
I was worried maybe it looked like you guys were stepping on my hand or something, but it turned out fine.
That's the worst pain.
Have you had your hand stepped on before?
Oh, yeah, like the full body weight.
It's not good.
Thankfully, it didn't happen, though.
I know some people actually broke their hands, too.
I knew a kid when I was younger, it was like all the neighborhood kids got on a shopping cart and the kid who was on the bottom, the rack where you put heavy stuff, we were going down a hill and his pinky got caught under the wheel and he had to go to the emergency room because it pretty much came off.
Oh my god!
That's crazy.
I heard that you can reattach any body part unless you have the body part.
Well, not your head, obviously.
Oh, well, yeah.
But your limbs and stuff.
You can reattach any of your limbs as long as you still have the body part.
Yeah, it's kept intact.
And then they reattach the nerves and everything and you can use it.
It has to be within under 24 hours, though.
Oh, yeah.
Or else it dies.
The nerves and stuff, you just can't.
You'll still be able to move, too, with it and shit.
So, I like how some people say, wait, then Winter Soldier can be real.
Wait, wait, what do you mean?
Is it his lore or something?
His arm is like a mechanic arm.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's possible, yeah.
Oh, wait, apparently you're frozen.
Oh, you are frozen.
What, really?
Oh, I think I minimized by accident.
You're just looking up.
Oh, wait, I see what it is.
There we go.
Did that fix it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It fixed it.
I didn't even know when you were frozen.
No, it just happened because all my windows got minimized.
Are you planning on getting GM, Juby?
Probably not.
Why not?
You were so close last time.
It takes so much time, I think.
What do you mean?
We got you to play.
Maybe.
I'll play it like every other day.
I believe in the Juby GM.
I believe in it.
You almost got to there.
It was so close.
I was like halfway to the bar thingy.
Hold on, sorry, I'm multitasking so my brain...
I just realized that on my stream, you're kind of see-through.
Oh, am I?
Yeah, it's because I messed with the Chrome.
Oh, you messed with the Chrome.
Oh, there it goes.
Okay.
Even though we're almost done.
We fixed it.
It's because you were smaller before, so you couldn't really tell.
It's okay, guys.
We fixed it now.
I have the same problem with mine because I have pink and green.
That's so true.
It's hard to find a color.
Because of the green screen.
And I have a red eye, so I couldn't do red, so I was like...
I showed really bright purple or something.
It's just your pin disappears a little bit.
Because it's kind of purple.
Oh, that's true.
That's not right.
It's really dark.
It's not that important.
Oh, my God.
You should introduce me.
Some of my chat got a great idea, but you should show me some of the Roblox games you play.
Okay, well, I only play two, but...
I'll show you the squid game one.
It's called Takeoff.
I'll send a picture.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot I was going to send you the... Wait, let me send you the...
the video of the Wolverine.
I need you to...
Is it like, there's two wolves inside of me?
Yeah, it's like, you know the song Animals?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me find it.
Or my mod can find it.
Because I don't know.
It's been a while, guys.
Since I looked at that video.
It's a great video.
Pull up the clip.
It's like...
Oh, my God.
I need to find that video.
It's so difficult.
I've been like...
I think I sent it to like five people already.
Because it's just... I'll be like, have you seen this clip?
And they're like, no.
I was like, you have to see it.
It's like, stop everything and just watch this video.
Well, what do you use to find memes?
Because I know some people just use Twitter.
I just use Twitter or Instagram.
Yeah, it's this one.
I'll show it to my chat, too.
It's actually one of my favorite Marvel Rival memes.
You know how the Twitter's algorithm and stuff?
People were like, oh, man.
Oh, this VTuber drama.
All that shit.
All this other drama and stuff.
And then my Twitter algorithm is really just Marvel Rival memes.
It's Marvel Rival memes and artwork.
Like...
It's better that way.
Yeah, that's all it is.
They're like, oh, man.
Yeah, the awoooo.
Awoooo.
I fucking love that meme.
It's one of my... and then I love it when all the Wolverine players are going to be like, awoooo.
Awoooo.
Honestly, I was surprised that I like Marvel Rivals as much as I did or anybody liked it as much as they do.
And also, it makes me feel like I like the Marvel characters more.
Like, I'm actually influenced to be more interested in them and their lore and stuff.
And then, like, because you already know the characters before you play.
Like, overwatch, you have to learn the characters from the interaction stuff while you're playing.
But, like, Marvel Rivals, you already know there's so many other spin-off shows and stuff like that, too.
And I think the skins are a lot better, too.
I think.
Oh, better than Overwatch?
Yeah, there's more relatability for the skins cause you're like, oh, it's from that comic, or it's from that movie.
Yeah.
Well, I mean having a huge franchise is kind of like, well, I mean, of course you can fail, but I feel like it's harder to beat you DC.
Yeah, yeah, it's harder.
Hahaha!
DC hasn't figured it out.
It hasn't.
Honestly, like, the Commando show is really good.
It's fine.
But other than that, I haven't been interested much with a lot of the DC...
I think, like, DC animated movies are really, really I love DC animated movies.
I haven't seen them.
I was gonna say maybe DC, they could make an animated, or sorry, a MOBA game.
Oh, that's true!
Like Pokemon Unite.
Pokemon Unite was pretty good.
Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think Pokemon Unite was pretty good.
And if they do some sort of MOBA for it, I think people would really enjoy it.
But like, um, for DC, yeah.
It would be funny if DC does a hero shooter too.
If they do a hero shooter.
I don't know.
I mean, they see the success.
Marvel Rivals made so much money on skins alone, I read.
From just the skins.
And battle pass and stuff.
Yeah, just the battle pass.
I mean, it's really helpful with the fact that they're like, the battle passes don't expire.
So you can technically buy older battle passes if you want to.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Like, I feel like...
I feel like they'll...
I don't know, I think that's such a good idea.
Because it means newer players can still give money for older battle passes.
Oh wait, DC already have a MOBA?
They have a MOBA?
What the hell?
I didn't know that.
I did not know that either.
DC MOBA.
Oh my god, they do.
When did it die?
It discontinued in 2015.
Oh!
Oh my god, that's 10 years ago!
Oh my god, it was called like...
That's crazy.
Infinite Crisis Battle Arena Video Game.
Wait, what?
Maybe it was too...
They were too...
Yeah, it was just...
They were too early, you know.
They were...
They should bring it back.
They should try it again.
Maybe people will be interested?
Yeah.
Maybe they'll die like...
I guess die like Heroes of the Storm, I guess.
Well, at least they still have the servers.
At least Heroes of the Storm servers are still up.
It's still going.
It's still sort of going, yeah.
It's much more fun than League, trust me.
Wait, really?
You have to buy for your build and stuff.
Heroes of the Storm, you just upgrade your abilities.
You don't have to buy items.
Oh, like...
What makes it easier than League?
Well, yeah, just that you don't have to buy items.
You just upgrade abilities and play like...
Oh, it's just...
So there's not like a million items to upgrade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's just like...
It's like Deadlock, basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It works really similar.
Except Deadlock does have items too, but...
Yeah, yeah, but like...
It's like upgrades and items.
But like...
So like...
It's the same thing.
But they just removed the items part.
Yeah, yeah.
How do you think about Deadlock?
I'm not sure if you enjoyed it.
I haven't played it in like a few months, I think.
It was pretty fun though.
I think like after Marvel Rivals came out, everyone just forgot about Deadlock.
The thing is with Deadlock, it takes so much more...
You have to pay really close attention to make sure you're farming the souls and everything.
Yeah.
That's true.
The farming part is...
I love the...
The like...
The shooting for it.
The shooting mechanics and the fighting.
But oh my god.
When I have to do the fucking farming part.
The farming the creeps and like...
I just want to go crazy.
I was like...
Like the 10 minutes of looking at each other and farming creeps is so...
I'm so bored.
Can we just shoot each other?
I think that's it too.
I get too impatient in that game.
Yeah, me too.
I end up not doing the stuff that I need to do.
Farming creeps because it's boring.
Yeah, I feel that.
I feel that a lot.
I'm just like...
Please, I can't.
I can't shoot these guys again.
Just shoot me.
And then when you shoot them...
They're so busy farming creeps.
They run away.
And I'm like...
Fight me.
Why are you running away?
Just because you're not as far?
I feel like even more than Marvel Rivals.
I mean, I know Marvel Rivals are supposed to be having huge team fights.
But if you're doing a 3v3 on one side of the map.
That's fine.
But for Deadlock, you need the whole team there.
Yeah, you need the whole 6v6.
Or one person missing just fucks up everything.
It needs to be balanced.
On how many people are in the fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They haven't actually launched yet for Deadlock.
So maybe they'll change.
Remember it was closed beta?
It was invite only.
So it's not actually launched yet to everybody.
But it was so easy to get an invite anyway.
I think it's open beta now.
Well, yeah.
It's been a while since it's been out.
For Alpha.
I think it's still beta.
But you still need an invite for it.
You still need to have someone invite you to join the game.
It's not open yet.
So maybe...
I think Valve has to be afraid of Marvel Rivals.
Because before there was zero competition for them.
Yeah, it was open season.
People kind of forgot about hero shooters a little bit.
Because Overwatch is dead and there wasn't really anything else.
I honestly did not expect Marvel Rivals to pop up as much as it did.
Because I got invited since closed Alpha.
I've been playing since closed Alpha.
And people kept asking me like, Do you think this is going to be the next game?
And I'm like, I don't know.
It's third person.
And I was playing it all the way till closed Alpha to beta.
And I never got hooked.
But then rank opened.
And I was like, oh my.
I get it now.
I was like, I get it now.
Oh my god.
I understand.
For you, it's like the aspiration of getting to the top.
It's just the competitiveness.
It's always fun.
And then seeing yourself get higher and higher.
Just improving more and more.
That's my motivation for competitive.
I can't play quick play.
Legitimately, I would rather bash my head against the wall than play quick play.
That's fair.
You're just not doing anything.
There's no stakes.
There's no challenge.
There's no fear.
Have you ever played Counter Strike?
No, I never played CS.
Or CSGO.
It's a tactical shooter.
I've always wanted to learn CS.
I've always wanted to.
But then, it felt like...
Especially grenade angles.
Oh, callouts.
And callouts too.
I was playing with people for CS.
He's in...
Snake or some shit.
And I'm like, what the fuck is Snake?
They're under...
These are some weird fucking callouts.
There it is.
Is there actually a place called Banana in CS?
Oh, yeah.
What the fuck is Banana?
It's shaped like a banana.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've always wanted...
You should try playing.
I could teach you the map callouts.
Oh, yeah.
They have a game mode called Wingman where it's only two people.
And it's in parts of the map.
So you would be able to learn different parts pretty easily.
I'm down to learn.
I've always wanted to learn CS too.
You're just like, it's finally someone to play CS with.
Yeah.
I'm converting some people.
I got some friends to play.
Oh, thank you.
It's actually pretty decent.
It's your turn to boost me.
I'm not really ranked highly in CS right now either.
I got pretty high.
What's your highest rank?
MG2.
MG2?
That's something Guardian, right?
Yeah.
That's pretty high.
That's like the Eagle, right?
Yeah.
MGE is the Eagle.
That's why there's an E.
Oh, that's one rank.
You were almost at the Eagle.
Yeah, but I wasn't there for very long.
That's pretty high.
Yeah, that's pretty...
Wait, how much...
What's your skin total?
Actually, I don't know.
I do have a knife skin, but it's not very cool.
It's just like a Safari mech.
Were you not opening cases and stuff for CS?
Yeah, but I never get anything.
I must have opened like 300 or 400 cases.
What the fuck?
How many?
The only thing I got was like an M4 skin.
Oh my god!
What?
I was saving... I saved up cases for maybe like 6 or 7 years and finally I opened a shit ton of...
There was no gacha luck there.
That's crazy.
That's...
Oh my god, did you...
I bought skins though off of the marketplace.
Now it looks cool.
Like knife skins or just gun skins?
Just skins that I like.
They're green colored.
There's like glove skins.
Wait, there's skins for gloves now?
There's operator skins, yeah.
Oh.
I got operator skins.
Oh my gosh, your account must be worth a lot.
Maybe.
Maybe I should do one of those steam estimates.
Yeah, you should do a steam estimate just to see how much there are in total.
Wait, I could probably...
You just have to have your steam like public, right?
I don't know.
Inventory?
As a person who doesn't play CS.
I was like, 99% of gamblers quit before they win.
Like, open for cases.
Yeah, but I ran out of cases.
It's like be back to 2010 where you do like case openings in video.
I bought 100 CS cases and we're gonna open them now, live on stream.
Yeah.
For the whatever knife.
It's still popular.
Yeah, yeah, you should totally...
Guys, if you donate, she'll do a case opening stream.
If you wanna buy $100 worth of cases, you're gonna spend like $800 or something.
It's $800?
For 100 cases?
People sell cases for...
It depends on what case you buy, but some of them sell for like $4 or $8 or $7 and so on.
I don't think cases are that cheap right now either.
Alright, guys.
What do you call your fans, Doobie?
Oh, I don't have a name for them yet.
Alright, Dooberts.
You guys, it's $800.
Dooberts, it's $800 for 100 cases.
Here is that.
No, no.
Then I'll actually have to do it.
I promise.
Oh, no.
You have to open cases.
It's not worth it.
You don't get anything.
But what if you get a cool knife, Doobie?
I'd rather buy a knife.
You can get a really cool knife for $800.
But the thrill!
The thrill of opening...
I've experienced the thrill and I've been let down too many times.
But 99% of gamblers quit before they win.
You could be the 1%.
Actually, I do have some cases like on an old account.
Oh, you can like ship the...
Yeah, you can like... Can't you like send cases to...
Oh, no.
Bring back 2010, Doobie.
Bring it back.
No, people are still doing case openings.
It's not something from like...
How many years ago was that?
15 years ago?
Yeah, but then you can be the VTuber that does it, you know?
You can say that, but how many VTubers does a case opening stream?
There's like 1.
No, there's 0 and it's gonna be 1 because you'll be the pioneer.
Pioneer.
Pioneer it.
You'll bring it back.
You'll start a new craze.
Maybe I can find a video of somebody opening cases and just say that I'm opening them.
Yeah, and then just play it and you put yourself on top of their screen.
Easy content.
So...
Now you'll... Hey, maybe this stream wasn't even my gameplay in the end.
Maybe I just recorded it and put it over.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We just recorded this.
We prerecorded it, the gameplay and then we just put ourselves on top of it because it's too hard gaming and playing at the same time.
I hired somebody to play on my account actually.
This isn't even my account, so...
Yeah, yeah.
I'm actually playing on her account right now.
She hired me actually.
You played both of them at the same time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have like those paddles and stuff at the bottom where I can move.
Did you see that streamer that tried to play Marble Rivals with her fucking brain?
No, I haven't seen that.
Oh my god.
I saw it.
It was on Shroud's Fragathon.
He had this girl that was on his stream.
It analyzes her brainwaves to move the controls and stuff.
And it was crazy because she did that for Elden Ring, I think.
She beat Elden Ring with just her mind.
Oh, yeah.
I do remember seeing that.
Yeah, yeah.
And then she did that and then she tried to do that with Marble Rivals.
It was crazy just seeing how her fucking brainwaves was like moving the character and stuff.
And she could aim with that, too.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
But yeah, that's what I'm doing right now.
One of them I played with my brain and the other...
I don't know if that's possible.
Two at once?
So when Doobie was saying she was lagging, it was because my brainwaves was like fucking up.
It was because I was lagging IRL in my brain.
But yeah, that was fun, though, Doobie.
You had a great time.
Thanks for joining me for some Rivals.
Thank you for inviting me.
Yeah, I'm gonna talk to you in my chat, but I definitely had a great time playing with you.
You gotta teach me CS later and then we gotta do Heroes of the Storm.
We gotta drag Mimi to do Heroes of the Storm, too.
Yippee!
We're gonna...
I think we're gonna...
Dude, I think we're gonna revitalize Heroes of the Storm.
They're gonna look at the data and we're...
Peak player base?
We're gonna bring Heroes of the Storm a peak player base for the last year.
We're saving Heroes of the Storm, guys.
I think when people stream it, the viewers also wanna play.
I've seen that happen before.
Yeah.
We're gonna save Heroes of the Storm, guys.
Oh my god, the doobie spin.
I was trying to do something, but then I realized it doesn't work like that on my stream.
It's like a different window that I have.
It looked cool on my...
It looked cool on my stream.
That's okay.
It looked cool here.
Oh my god.
Jeez, rotate.
Do a flip.
Whoa!
She did it!
Oh my god.
I saw so many angles.
You guys can't see it.
Wow.
Doki bird exclusive, guys.
Yeah, gg's doobie.
I had a great time.
Let's do something again soon.
Alright.
Bye bye.
Go talk to your doobers.
I'm sorry if that ended up being the name.
Unofficial name.
They need something.
What's keeping you from deciding a name?
I just haven't been able to find something that sounds good.
Wait, get some fan suggestions.
Unless you don't think they sound good.
No, they didn't sound good.
Sorry.
They're like, passengerbs.
Doinguses.
I don't know.
They're not good.
What about dooberts?
Doobie and the dooberts.
I'll think about it.
I'll put it in the hat.
Yeah, put it in the hat.
Alright, gg's, doobie, gg's.
Bye bye.
Oh my god, it was so fun!
I had a great time playing with doobie and talking to her.
And honestly, I hope that doobie and the unofficial dooberts can figure out a name for them.
I'm so sorry you guys ended up doobie-ing called dooberts.
I think that is not really the best name.
That's the first thing that came out of my head.
I was thinking about dobert.
It was really fun.
I'm really happy that we could finally play together.
Because we were trying to play Marvel Rivals for a while, but then I got into my...
Like I said, she wanted to play Marvel Rivals for a while now.
But then I got stuck in my Marvel Rivals rank run.
And this week I was like, oh my god, this is it.
I can do it.
I can play Marvel Rivals.
Or like last week, I was like, I can do it.
Oh my god, I can finally do it.
I'm out right now.
I'm out of the...
I'm out of the pit.
I climbed out.
But I had a lot of fun.
Thank you everyone for the super chats too.
Thank you guys.
And thank you again for all the raiders and for Nimi for raiding.
I was very surprised.
Nimi and I were talking in the DMs earlier.
I was just congratulating her for her debut and stuff.
And we want to do something together in the future too.
I'm really happy for the Nimi raid that came along.
I hope she's happy.
She had a great day and she had a great time.
And it was definitely a really fun stream.
I wanted to help Doobie get to plat and then call it there.
So yeah, I definitely am glad we got to plat.
Honestly, I don't care about the rank of my account.
So I'm glad we were able to get her there.
Even though it was an alt account, I love her name.
DND.
Dookie and Doobie.
Or Doobie and Dookie.
But yeah, I had a great time.
I saw someone.
It's gonna have a birthday tomorrow because I won't be streaming tomorrow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tomorrow is Hitominty's birthday.
Can you sing her happy birthday?
Of course I can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Hitominty.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Tomorrow!
But yes, for those who are...
I guess I should show some stuff before I go.
But if you are new here, if you see the link, I do have a Nendoroid preorders out right now.
And it's gonna be gone in two to three weeks or something.
So if you wanna support me, please preorder the Nendoroid because if we get enough sales, we might be able to have a second Nendoroid with my corn skin suit.
So yes!
Everybody, I pinned it in my chat.
So I can copy and paste it too.
There we go.
Okay, I fucked up the link, I think.
No, it's okay.
The link is fine.
I think it's...
I don't know.
Preorder Nendoroid!
Preorder!
Chill, chill, chill!
Thank you for buying my merch!
Whoa!
But thank you guys so much.
I had a great time playing.
I always get really nervous between collabs.
Collabs always make me incredibly nervous because, like I said, I don't...
I always be like, I hope we all have fun.
I really hope.
And then we can just keep talking and just chill and hang out and have discussions and stuff like that.
So I'm really happy that we had a great time talking.
And it was really great talking to Doobie and just listening to her insight and things and stuff.
But yeah, I hope you guys had fun too, watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!